tv show what's that i don't watch tv
shows just [ __ ] up
they watch your animations oh let's not
pretend you still watch anime joey come
on let's
be real here
welcome to this episode of trash taste i
am the boy the big boy
and with me i have big boy chungus and
small boy chungus
wow why am i suddenly the fattest one
here
i've been seeing either of you at the
gym lately i don't know what's been
going on with that but you know i'm very
disappointed i mean who was the one that
got a c
in cholesterol that's the [ __ ] like
yeah i'm gonna start adding each other
i wanted to like that i wanted to open
on that because you know what
i was uh i was you know i was doing my
usual trash taste um
schedule and uh [ __ ] on the toilet
literally before recording gotta get a
get a phone call from sydney yeah and
she said oh i finally get my health
health results back in i'm like
congratulations what'd you get sydney
and she got all a's
how is it that she gets all a's and yet
i got a c on my liver
i'm probably the one out of the four of
us who drinks the least okay
okay so so to give context this
conversation so a few weeks ago if
you're a regular trash taste viewer
you would know that we had our bi-annual
annual health check annual health check
and
which is something that a japanese
company forces every employee to do they
have to go for a checkup and the company
also gets the results yes yes
and so we we did our health check up a
few weeks ago talked about it on trash
taste
and we just got our results back and
this is the first time i've ever gotten
results back
from like uh you know getting my health
check up in a foreign company
uh country sorry and i did not know that
you get graded yeah i'm used to seeing
numbers and then saying like oh this is
bad i'm like oh well i mean it's just a
funny number isn't it yeah yeah yeah
no no you it literally i got my health
check up and i'm just like
wait they are literally grading you abc
like it's like an end-of-year school
report yeah
i felt like i was doing my gcses again
or a-levels like
my god and normally i don't really care
too much
about my health check-up because
unless it's bad right you see numbers
you see you know you see the doctor's
suggestions and they're they're just
that they're
doctor's suggestions but i don't know
why i think it's
seeing seeing my health being graded
like a school test
it just brought the asian blood out of
me right yeah yeah
yeah i was i definitely felt more
competitive yeah with my body
because i was going through my health
checkup and overall i i got a b
so i was like okay i am a straight a
student
what is what the [ __ ] does this
the first thing i did when i got my
results was i phoned up my mum
and told her that and told her how well
i scored in this exam like a good asian
song
i called up the doctor and i was like
just a check this wasn't ranked was it
this was this is casual right
this is free play right please say
please say this society
please say no but yeah so i mean my
results i got like all a's which is
great as you'd expect from someone who
is under the age of 30. you're
generally supposed to be quite healthy
right yeah yeah but i got i got a b
on bmi yeah which i mean obviously i'm
built a little different
right yeah and this is japanese bmi
which i believe is slightly different i
don't know if
i'm led to believe that's correct but
yeah but i mean bmi is [ __ ] anyway
a lot of [ __ ] this is a hundred percent
muscle not fat don't happen
and i got a c on my cholesterol all
right but i got
i got like uh well i'm not sure how
cholesterol work exactly because i don't
know [ __ ] i'm dumb
but one of so there was like they had
like three different cholesterols and
all of them were like a little
you know all of them were kind of out of
touch right right right
um but i was like in my head i'm like
well they gave me three c's now for my
cholesterol like but what are the odds
of one of these cholesterol being good
and the others not being good right if i
go ahead and amazing cholesterol the
other two aren't going to be like well
[ __ ] i mean where
i'm gonna pick it up i mean i don't know
to me it was odd i mean mine was worse
because i got a c
on my liver and i think a b on my heart
rate monitoring or something
right really and everything else was an
a what does that mean
that's the thing right it's like usually
on your thing like i think you two got
like a doctor's like
note right or like a doc did you guys
get a doctor so you can ask
when you get the thing i don't know if
you said yes or no you can ask if you
want advice
right and i said no i don't want advice
i i said no you don't want to but i
still go like i've got i don't know if
it's the same doctor's note that we're
talking about right but it was just like
a
summation of the test results which
didn't explain anything no it didn't
excite
it just said um some of the values are a
bit you know abnormal which is you know
higher or lower than we expect
but there shouldn't be anything to worry
about i didn't even get a summation did
you know my mind literally like
overall i got a c and the summation box
was just blank i was like
oh yeah yeah you're just going to tell
me that my liver is bad and that's it
yeah i feel like should i be worried
some context would help yeah
did did you have to get did you get a
note that said you had to come in three
months later as well
like i did i got that they told me back
in three months but i don't but it's
optional i mean on the thing it says
like if you get a c
they recommend you come back three
months later but i didn't get like a
note saying that i should come back
so yeah mine said you should come back
yeah yeah yeah you have to pay for it
and also i you know for cholesterol
he's oh i'm obviously going to turn up
and they're going to be like hey you
should uh
exercise and eat healthy i'm like thanks
dog i was going to ask because
i heard i heard you're back on the
chicken and broccoli diet no no i
haven't gone right back to the chicken
breast okay i haven't i have started
eating a little more health
consciousness is it because of the test
results i think it helped helped me be a
bit more conscious it made me
you know when you would you would maybe
just go for the karate or you would go
for the chips it may
be a little bit like second thing like i
mean i i definitely have like
stopped drinking okay
i think i've only drank like once or
twice is is is the liver 100
all problems come from alcohol because i
feel like it's not just probably there's
gonna be a whole host of others
because the problem with the test
results is that they they gave they gave
you the grade
but they didn't tell you how to improve
it and i guess i guess that was bad
because we literally
ticked the box that said we don't want
doctor's advice because i i had assumed
like any other health checkup that it
would just be like you know that you're
going to be good right yeah it was just
like the generic
you know are you doing well do i need to
go to the hospital to really
have a lifestyle change no but as soon
as i saw the [ __ ] bee
because i got a i got a b in my blood
and i'm just like how the [ __ ] do i
improve my blood
what am i doing wrong why is my blood at
b just improve your men
just like control it like because they
were they were like they were like going
on like
you know the the white blood or t cell i
don't
i'm not a [ __ ] i i i
yeah i saw the b and i'm just like as as
as an asian student you know because
whenever i saw a b in a test i'm like
okay i can improve this test score
i can study a bit more i can optimize
this a bit more somehow
what i found interesting was that like i
always thought to myself that
i was very deaf for my age like because
you know i went to like a lot of
concerts growing up and just
[ __ ] basically destroyed my easter
like headphones and [ __ ] like that yeah
but so i was expecting like on the
hearing part
that i maybe get like a b or something
right i wouldn't even have complained
about it but then i saw i got an a
yeah so i was like oh it's not that i'm
deaf it's just that i don't listen
it kind of made me realize i was like oh
okay
i'm glad to know i don't have a hearing
problem i just have like an attention
problem i just don't give a [ __ ] that's
not that's my that's my problem
i was telling the company i was like
listen if my eyesight or my ears come
back [ __ ] i know exactly why that is and
that's because i don't know what the
[ __ ] was happening when they were
talking to me oh yeah they just put the
headphones on me i'm like wait what wait
whoa whoa whoa
they were like can you then she asked me
luckily i just caught her asking can you
hear in japanese
like can you hear it and i'm like here
what what am i listening for like and
then i realized because i had done the
human benchmark test
right right recently that it was the
frequency thing yeah yeah same way you
can hear it yeah but i was like what are
you what do you want me to
like what am i hearing for like a bulb
like what i didn't know what was
happening
but i was like oh okay [ __ ] all right
how did you because with the eyesight
thing right you have to do like the
it's like a circle yeah yeah it's cut
out right yeah yeah how did you guys say
that in english oh
no i said it in japanese what do you
just point out
because i i really [ __ ] up in the
eyesight thing because i didn't know
what they were like looking for right so
i thought it was like a normal eyesight
test thing where now when i was just
like uh
e yeah because because okay so
to explain the eyesight thing they have
this circle and have like one of like
either up down
left or right that's cartel and then
right now the diagonals as well cut out
i didn't see diagonals i didn't see
diagonals diagonals yeah there were
diagonals no
no no no i only saw up down left right
they were diagonal no because i caught
all of them right
yeah i did too but they were diagonal
there was no diagonals there was no
doubt my one they gave me they usually
have diagonals right
i've never seen diagonals because the
only reason i knew about this test is
because when i
exchanged my driving license from
british to japanese i had to do the
exact same thing
right yeah and i i was just it was this
exact same thing again
yeah and there was no diagonals i mean i
definitely got it right because i came
back with like a one point two she could
be like
just men talking about diagonals yeah i
don't know
yeah because right next to the circle
thing you had like the letters as well
so i was just reading out letters when
they were asking what direction
i would have said what direction was
missing from the song
because i was wondering why she was
looking at me really weird
and i'm just like and she kept asking me
can you see can you see and i'm just
like
yeah yeah yeah let me just read out the
letters for you so why are they
this is easy as [ __ ] yeah luckily i've
done the simulation before so that's
yeah i was right not panicking as much
but
yeah man i mean i i clicked no to the
health advice because i just figured
that it was going to be the same old
you know yeah just eat healthy listen
yeah because let's be honest right if
it's if it's
unless it's something you know bad like
really bad that actually requires
treatment
right they're just going to tell me hey
you should exercise more and eat healthy
yeah
you know i do most of that anyway yeah
because you know i mean like i think for
cholesterol it's pretty simple it's
pretty simple literally just
yeah but for some of them like for
example liver or blood
you look at that results in little yikes
yeah it's like it's like a number of
factors right like what do you
how do i improve my white blood cell
count i don't know do i just take an
injection
of why blood cells what do what do you
want me to do i have a theory right
this is this could be a very uh pleasant
theory i don't know
my theory was because we got the health
checkup done right after like christmas
and my theory was well i've just been
drinking and eating straight for like
three weeks this is clearly come on we
got to write this off this doesn't count
yeah
of course my collateral's going to be
higher i had like 8 000 calories three
days ago
of course it's gonna be higher sure
maybe i don't know
but i didn't drink a lot in christmas
so much yeah yeah i think that
definitely skewed the results that's
that's what i'm going to chalk it down
to i mean
doctors out there please validate me in
the comments
i don't want i don't want to hear if you
have an alternative theory just say if
i'm right
yeah i just found i just found it funny
how like i think it's
i think it's this is different
definitely the difference between like
asian culture
and like western culture where i feel
like in asia living in asia they try to
make everything a test and everything
kind of competitive and that's just
i that's how i was raised as well so
whenever i see a grade
i like something in my blood drives me
to try and improve that grade
yeah it's true yeah and i don't know if
i'm just like over competitive or
i just maybe well i think it's good
right because if you're the kind of
person who you are
yeah those things work really well but
there's obviously some personalities out
there that
when they hear oh by the way like your
bmi is bad or your live is bad where
they just like instead of like wanting
to be like well [ __ ] you i'm going to
improve it it's like
oh [ __ ] i guess it's just like there's
no hope like why why is it like
working and then it should make it worse
right yeah but i don't know i feel like
as as you know as someone who grew up in
you know kind of kind of both cultures
i think a lot of toxicity can come in
putting so much value
into a grade or a test and i feel like
definitely living in asia
they put way too much value into test
results and school results
do you think there are like some schools
and like companies where like they get
bullied if you got like a bad
rating i think it's totally i it's
definitely a thing in asia
because i heard because [ __ ] got
a d in his blood yeah because because in
in in asia i i i don't know if i'm
talking about my ass but
you see in like anime definitely where
you get the test results right
and it's like publicly posted yeah so
you you publicly know
what your fellow classmates got and
that to me seems like a lot of pressure
they do that for like university like
entrance exams as well they're like
yeah but create a huge billboard in
front of the school and it has like your
number on it and if your number doesn't
show up you basically fail yeah brother
so it's like a public execution they
literally make a public tournament arc
for your test results
like no one no wonder they put so much
value and testing
and i think that can that can definitely
that
to me from my experience can definitely
skew with your mentality when you
go out of schooling and you realize that
not everything in
life is graded and not everything in
life has a percentage or a grade that
uh judges your results and how well you
do yeah i think especially because
given the industry that we've gone into
which is entertainment if you will
uh then if you call trash taste
entertainment but we're trying our best
here
um i feel like the skill set is nearly
180 it compares of what what you learn
in school
right it's purely based on like i feel
like social skills and 90 percent of our
job oh yeah right being able to read a
room
yeah like talk but you know and i mean
obviously there is a lot of technical
aspect obviously like learning how to
set up all this equipment
but the majority of it can't be taught
in a classroom oh no and it's kind of
and
i mean you know how can you grade
someone's social skills imagine we
started doing that
oh i mean did you imagine oh
connor you know you were on s but ever
since the event happened
you've been kind of a bomber you're kind
of a d now you know what i mean
like yeah it's like it's like getting
graded for every tweet you make right
yeah
honestly if you're like if you're just
like oh how's the b plus tweet yeah yeah
yeah that's true
yeah he's just gonna fight away i mean i
went through a period in life where
you know i was the stereotypical weave
that didn't go out and i had
zero social skills and how i learned was
i think everyone goes through that stage
especially if you go through university
where you kind of want to
you kind of want to reinvent yourself
right you move into someone new and you
want to
be a new person so what i did was i
basically just had like a full year
where i just went out as much as
possible
and talked to as many people as possible
just like try to go out my comfort zone
and that was [ __ ] hell for me as like
this introvert
it's kind of like a trial by fire period
of my life that i would never want to do
300 spartan training social strategies
it basically was because i
i literally i literally just did not
know how to socialize i didn't know how
to read a room i didn't know what the
social network was that's like such a
common like cultural thing in japan that
we actually have like our own
like phrase for it which is university
debut yeah
really it's like it's like a cultural
thing in japan where like because there
are so many like anti-social kids
in middle school and high school and
that when they go into university
they're like oh [ __ ] i'm like one step
closer to
where i have to socialize in order to
[ __ ] live
in society so university is literally my
last chance before i'm
thrown into that world so i'm gonna like
make a 180 during university and just
[ __ ] do
anything and everything possible to just
completely change myself around
i think it is a really op mindset when
you when you you know because
you know i wasn't cool at all in school
i was i was like
very much an in-betweener you know i
wasn't cool but i wasn't like i wasn't
like on the bottom of the social ladder
if you will you weren't like bullied to
[ __ ] right
i mean that's because i started fighting
back my way out of there
you know i was just kind of like
whatever like nobody paid attention to
me never had any luck with like
you know dating or anything yeah i was
never had any of that but then i thought
like
oh wait like no one knows who i am in
university
yeah so like i don't know no one knows
i'm a mid-tier social
i'm a i'm a ct on the social ladder
you know i didn't reinvent myself it's
just like you don't do the mistakes you
don't
fall back on crutches that you had like
like don't like you said right you go
out more you don't
you know i could play video games which
is what i probably would prefer doing
but
if people invite me out i'll say yes
because you want to be seen as fun and
then seems fine everything goes easier
and you learn more you get more
confident
if for me it was go out of your comfort
zone for me it was like the complete
opposite
i was like the really social in middle
school in high school and then when i
entered university because i started
doing youtube yeah right i like kind of
regressed social media you also lived at
home right yeah i lived at home i can
imagine that's like
way you must feel did you feel like
different from like the other people who
are living on campus
oh yeah a little bit i mean our campus
was weird because
i think the majority of people in my
class did live at home oh wow yeah we
only had maybe like
a handful of people who actually lived
on campus which uh which
which university did you go to again uh
sydney university okay so i guess it's
because it's a city university yeah i
mean we have our own campus and like
dormitories and stuff like that
that uni students live in but i think
the majority of people because it's such
a
an accessible university because it's
like smack bang in the middle of like
sydney like city so people can just like
get on trains and buses and just go home
basically yeah because i i feel like no
one in my class
who lived locally to the area really
from there well that's because you went
to swansea right and yeah
what is there to do in swansea well it's
a good question guys
i'm still wondering that myself
i didn't live locally either i live like
an hour and a half by
bus [ __ ] so i didn't live close at all i
could have like i was at a distance
where i could have easily lived on the
dorm but then
i heard from people who were living in
dorms in sydney university they were
like don't do it that's a good
experience though
you know being thrown into hell honestly
i i feel like i learned
more valuable social skills um and just
life skills going to university
than i did actual career skills that i
was
using that that i learned from my course
i don't think i realized it until i left
and then i actually started like
functioning
yeah on my own yeah i don't i don't know
what i would have done without that
period in my life jesus said like
it basically taught me how to survive in
the world
and how people really are and all the
expectations i had
growing up and like because as a kid
right
you kind of expect that as you grow up
and the more mature you get you assume
that everyone's just gonna
realize what they're doing get mature
and then you kind of realize
um going through university especially
especially that that was a [ __ ] lie
and then you go out of university you
start like the working world and you
realize oh everyone here is just like
growing up university students and
everyone
nobody actually knows what they're doing
and everyone is still
secretly as immature adults aren't as
adult
as i thought they were right yeah i
don't know i feel like i don't
it's either like people just have their
[ __ ] together or they don't like there's
no in-between like i don't know i've
never met anyone
most adults that i've met are just like
kids in suits essentially
that's basically the best way i can
describe it and um
it's it's especially especially here
it's like seeing some of the recent
stuff
that's been happening um obviously stuff
like let's uh can we can we talk about
how uh the stonker market can we talk
about the stock market that's uh that
we've recently just seen
yeah we're going to be very delayed we
are going to be very delayed because
it's so worried so what's it just
happened to us it's just happened
or is is happening i don't [ __ ] know
it's a constantly evolving situation by
so by the time this airs it's probably
everything we're probably going to be
saying is going to be outdated yeah
um who knows the stock market might not
even exist by the time yeah my god when
reality is this entertaining who the
[ __ ] needs tv this is what i'm saying
that's what i've always said
real life is so much more interesting
yeah you couldn't make a movie
about like if you'd pitch the movie
being like right so what happens is a
bunch of redditors right
they buy gamestop stock and they like
they [ __ ] over these billion dollar head
like
no no everyone thinks that's [ __ ]
stupid yeah it happens this is the
coolest [ __ ] story yeah
yeah thus documentaries are better than
movies yeah and i just think we are
reaching a time period
where you know it used to be a you know
a funny meme but now
memes are just real life memes
big memes now are basically just making
fun of like
real life events yeah you know and
having a real life
effect on the world that is that is the
modern that is what memes are growing
inside
i think i think i saw someone on twitter
saying though like this is like kind of
the revitalization of it's just a prank
bro but
the pranks have just like gone actually
gone far like gone wrong
yeah i'm not gonna lie the first time i
saw that story i was like
i don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
and i'm really scared to ask
dude i i like when it was happening i
was like what the [ __ ] does shorting a
stock mean yeah and now i'm just like
now because of this meme i've done so
much research that i'm just like
maybe i should get into the stock market
you know
it's it's it's really weird because i
have not your life now
you know that youtube look i'm not i'm
not a gambling addict okay as much as as
much as the gadget
episode uh might have it might have made
me look like i'm not a gambling addict
you're yellow on gotcha but not only
but it's made me think a lot about my
you know grown-up investment
like uh grown-up investments uh talk
that i just went with
because i've been doing stocks like
through
like my dad because my dad is like
really missing so i've been doing it but
when this [ __ ] happened i was like
should i be scared
like what's happening i don't i don't
know what that dad is on money he's my
dad is my money
daddy daddy please is my money okay
please
yeah i mean no one no one in my family
has anything about it i mean yeah
you know i think my my family always i
think every single generation of my
family is just like made enough to get
by
right yeah do buy some nice things here
and there yeah so
they don't think stocks was ever on
their mind i think my my parents had
some stocks in the companies they worked
for as like a gift right yeah so i think
my dad checks up on those stocks but in
terms of actually
knowing about the stock market yeah you
know no one in my family has any idea
well right because it's not something
that you know everyone commonly learns
right but
that's that's that's what i was thinking
fancy gambling for rich men yeah well
that's that's what it's like marketed as
right but
i mean i'm doing my research and like
probably
probably reading into this um you know
like i was thinking
why the [ __ ] aren't we taught this in
school because i feel like
especially knowledge on the stock market
a lot of the reasons why people don't
get into the stock market
from what i've realized is because
nobody knows [ __ ] about it it's it's
because no nobody was taught this in
school
and it sounds so complicated that nobody
has the effort
or energy to really read up and learn
about this i mean i didn't
and the only reason i started reading
about up about this was because
the [ __ ] stock market was on fire and
it turned into a massive meme i
literally
started reading up about this because of
a meme who would have thought that memes
get you to go into like
educational adventures it happens all
the time man
but hey but like what this made me think
was why wouldn't we talk about this in
school like there's so many
growing up there's so many life
essential like knowledge that
i think should be that that i think
everyone should know to be fair though
it's like i'm thinking back like when
you were like
15 14 right you wouldn't pay attention
you wouldn't have paid attention
no i mean they always say like oh why
didn't they teach kids about taxes in
school as well because i don't think
they're happy
no one would [ __ ] yeah i think even
if you aren't
even with taxes i do think that there
should have been something yeah yeah no
i agree there should be something so at
least you when you get to that point in
life
you are aware and you can go back to be
like oh
this is why it was important because
there's there's so many things like for
example
i don't know why they're like it's not
compulsory to have a financial
management course
in in in in school they should be they
should they
because financial management is such an
as like an
adult life essential skill and it's
something that you have to learn
by just by just either one your parents
teaching it to you
or two [ __ ] up and realizing that
this is an important skill you need to
know
instead of scores are like no let's
learn the quadratic equations yeah but
we'll need that but no let's learn
that's beautiful actually
yeah you're doing it on the quadratic
equation
let's let's let's learn that there are
180 degrees in the triangle
i've used that before in my life let's
learn about the tangents
and the cosine of the side is the
powerhouse
well you know i think i think why they
should be teaching
like taxes and financial advice in
school is not so that like
you get because obviously kids aren't
going to [ __ ] come out of school
being like hello let me do your taxes
yeah
just so that when they leave school it's
like it's on the back of their mind yeah
i've been taught that this is a thing
that's going to come up and that i
should learn how it works
for my value yeah exactly it's the whole
point of school i feel should be
at least preparing you for what you're
gonna face in the adult world and you
know there can be some specialized
courses yeah i
i i mean it up but i can understand why
they teach mathematics and algebra in
case you want to
pursue that right what i am saying is
there are so many
life essential knowledge that i had to
learn on the fly and everyone does and i
was just not taught this stuff in school
and i'm thinking
why the [ __ ] is this not taught in
school yeah and the thing is is that
like yeah you know people can argue
being like you know oh
who needs to know the [ __ ] quadratic
equation what people are going to like
architecture or like math-based stuff
but like yeah
financial advice and taxes like that it
doesn't matter what job you go into
you're going to have to deal with it as
an adult yeah i mean it's like
there's so many things in my school that
we were taught that like
were were replaceable in my mind like we
were taught like
we were like dude like media studies and
like jesus where we just like analyze
like newspapers and [ __ ] and just like
talked about like the media and how they
advertise this stuff
it's in my job now but i didn't even get
anything useful from that yeah i i had
to do that as well yeah
i didn't have to do that and then i did
like cooking which was stupid because
i'm let's be honest i'm not a good cook
as i'm sure guys will find that to be
honest
be honest make money get over easy
that's what it's all about yeah
no but like you could have replaced it
and i think that um
[ __ ] what was i going to say [ __ ] i
totally forgot my point now [ __ ] i'm
done
go back to you i'll i'll i'll figure it
out okay okay no i'm i'm just saying
like there's so many
important things in life that i just
don't know about like i you know like
for example i have no idea about
anything about mortgages or anything
like that and when i say mortgage you
say the word mortgage right
and you're like oh okay you are grown up
but you know you know yeah
as a kid you hear the word mortgage
you're just like i i don't need to worry
about that yeah that's grown-ups i had
to learn that [ __ ] on the fly i was like
i don't know what the [ __ ]
the thing is everyone should you know
aim to own a house or own some property
that's like the one of the final goals
in life right
and yeah it's no nobody's taught this
[ __ ] isn't it bad the only time i've
ever heard the word mortgage was in a
monopoly game
that's the only time i've heard and and
you know well i still would have never
still don't know how to mortgage in a
monopoly game yeah exactly i
i still i still have like the bare bones
basic idea about a mortgage because
i've i've not gone through the process
of buying house because that [ __ ] sounds
scary to me yeah it is
and i i did go and see uh uh mortgage
advice
just because i wanted to learn more
about it and my bank had it for like
they were like free
consultations i had no intention of
getting a mortgage i don't even know how
they work
yeah because i feel like you should know
yeah so i went and then
just this really awkward thing of like
so what do you what do you do and like
and i'm like oh well we see uh so i make
make videos about like anime this is the
time and then
he was like okay and he was like and
like this is your this is your income
and i was like yeah and he's like
it changed a lot in one year i'm like
yeah yeah it does that
it could go up or down i don't know i'm
not thinking i should just tell him as
little about my job as possible
this guy's a financial risk i'd give him
a mortgage
but yeah i mean it was it was it was
pretty standard stuff i mean there's
different rates and stuff but
yeah i mean i i had to sit down with
like al like family financial advisor he
basically like i had to go
through like that's the most privileged
thing you've ever said
i have never had a holy financialness no
it's because it's because my
my parents are like super into like
[ __ ] like the housing market like the
stock market and [ __ ] like that so it's
just like
you're an adult now you still sounds
privileged you can talk to this man in a
suit that
comes to our house every so often you
think is our lawyer i used to call him
our lawyer because i didn't know who the
[ __ ] this guy was i was like there's a
man in a suit he must be a lawyer
check your wealth joke this episode is
sponsored by
harry's quality grooming and shaving
supplies gentlemen
we all have beards except for garn who
shave
no i i do shave and that's why i use
harry's
man i just hate it when i have to choose
between price and quality but thank to
harry's that's no longer a problem i
have to suffer you mean you can get both
at the same time yes gone you can that's
illegal harry's delivers a close
comfortable shave at a fair price
only two dollars per refill god damn
harry's believes in quality
so much that they bought their own
factory in germany
connor's favorite country so you know
that it works
connor just how do they do it gone i'm
glad you asked harry's team combined a
simple ergonomic design
with five sharp blades they sourced
their steel from sweden
and manufactured their blades in their
world-class blade factory
isn't that a is that a fate arc are you
telling me that harry's has
min max shaving and shaving products
guys thank god harry's german factory is
one of the few select manufacturers
in the world that have mastered the
technology to create a gothic
arc the gold standard of blade razor
grinding
this sounds epic like an anime arc but
thank god they also stand behind the
quality of their blades so much
that they offer 100 money-back guarantee
on 100
right for a limited time harry's has an
exclusive offer for listeners of trash
taste new customers can get a hairy
starter set
and a free body wash for just three
dollars by going to harrys.com
that's over a 16 value for just
three measly dollars what did they get
out of that i'll tell you what they get
you'll get a five
blade razor weighted handle foaming
shaving gel a travel cover and a travel
size body wash that's an incredible deal
as joey just said that is an incredible
deal but you have to act fast while
supplies last
so go to harrys.com trash taste to
redeem your offer today
thank you to harry for sponsoring this
episode back to the video so then when i
you know became an adult and i started
making a little bit of money on youtube
they were like okay you can talk to our
lawyer now who turned out to be a
financial advisor so i was like okay
um i don't know what to do with this
money please help me because otherwise
it's just going to collect in a bank
probably do [ __ ] nothing and he's
like well you could you know
mortgage and i'm like that would i
i don't know that word yeah ideally
anyone with any kind of savings would
have a financial advisor sadly you know
you know it's it's kind of difficult to
get a good one or get one that even you
know
like understand yeah yeah
down to be like okay this is what i do
and he was like wait so you make videos
and you get paid to do that now like
yeah and he's like
okay i mean i would love a financial
advisor because i
there's like like there's so little i
know about it and
this this kind of this you know the wall
street's bets
thing that's been going on has really
just opened my eyes to
how little i know about this stuff that
i feel like i really should know
yeah yeah like a youtuber i've been
watching recently is a guy called
i think it's graham specter i think
yeah the millionaire guy who's like i
saw him in like other videos
where he was talking about it's it's he
he seems like the most grounded
millionaire i've
ever you know i couldn't stand him at
first he seemed like a dick
and then and i started watching him i
was like all right okay he's pretty cool
but he just came off as like an ass no
because
like the biggest thing that puts me off
is every episode he goes he does the
but don't forget to like and subscribe
if you like the video and
like no matter how cool a person you are
if you say it immediately and ironically
it just like
like yeah immediate turn off but like i
was watching some of the videos and some
of the
advice that he he gave which was some of
it was like just like
really basic financial advice about how
to like manage your money
and this the thing is he he gives advice
that
any person from any level of income can
you can like um
can can take to heart because uh like
one of the ideas that he
really tried to propagate is like no
matter how much you earn you can you can
everyone should get into the mindset
well that you can invest something yeah
that's that's what that's what i
because i i was i had grown up with the
mindset of like
people the word investment that's for
rich people that's for privileged people
i
i can't invest i don't have the money to
invest but even just investing like
a fraction of your paycheck or something
in the long term
can really help you financially and give
you a lot of financial stability and
this this is the stuff that we just we
were just never taught like
i i guess as well because you hear so
many horror stories about investments
going wrong and you also hear about like
you know people who take advantage of
people with like you know
find a fake financial advisor who says
i'll help you out with your money and
then just
runs off with it right yeah yeah exactly
it's so scary to trust someone with any
amount of money
yeah and you know if even if you have
like barely anything
it's still all you have right it's scary
to give that to someone yeah yeah like
oh i trust you
to take care of this because because the
way that i was taught up because uh you
know i i
i also didn't come from like the most
well-off family so did i
you didn't have a lawyer or a finance i
i don't know i didn't have a family
financially
i just gave joey's parents i thought
everyone had one of those i mean my
parents
my parents declared like bankruptcy when
i was a teenager it was you know it's oh
[ __ ]
yeah so you know i i was taught i was
like i grew up with the mentality that
you know you should try to keep your
money safe you should
you know gather up as much as possible
and i realized how much this mentality
had affected how i think about just
resources in general
so what what i realized is that i'm that
gamer right
i i am that gamer who whenever you know
you know whenever you play an rpg you
don't use anything
and you get you get it you get a rare
item don't use it i don't use it
and whenever i play like command and
conquer or something or some
rts games right i wait until i have a
[ __ ] ton of resources
and then i start buying stuff out and i
realized i realized this
this week when i when i was like where
did this come from and i realized oh
it's because that's just how i manage my
money and that's just
i i've always come in the mindset of
i've got to save this just in case of a
rainy day i can't invest it
i need to save it because you know
investing money might be
risky so it's better to just save it and
you know i i kind of realized this as i
was doing research and i
learned a lot about myself uh this past
week because of a [ __ ] meme
because a lot of like entrepreneurs are
like spending everything they have like
just goes like right into buying [ __ ]
like they have like no savings it's just
all the businesses
it's all just high risk high rewards
yeah but then also as well you know
online there's so much of those fake
stupid entrepreneurs
online that have just really like ruined
in my mind
the image of an entrepreneur dude speed
run ruin in like five years dude
if i go on like a twitter or a social
media and it has the word entrepreneur
on it right you know two years ago
yeah entrepreneur was probably one of
the coolest things you could say like
yeah
you're an entrepreneur now i just think
oh you're just doing a [ __ ]
multi-level marketing scam to me
oh you're selling me a course on how to
be more confident have you seen those
courses yeah
those things are insane they cost like
it's like 1k for the first course and
then they're like
all right now you've unlocked the
ability to get the next level of the
course for only five thousand dollars
and it blows my mind they're like trying
to teach you [ __ ] that can't be learnt
yeah it but it blows my mind that that
people buy into this stuff
because they're obviously just people
who have who are spending the money
you're giving them
on this lavish lifestyle but then they
sell back to you like
it's insane and i don't know how people
get sucked into this like
with like when we were talking about the
gambling stuff i can understand how
somebody can get into gambling you can
gamble away
i don't understand how someone can watch
these entrepreneurs right these fake
entrepreneurs talk about how
they can make you loads of money and
they can tell you how to be like there's
loads like real
realtors have you seen those yeah yeah
like i could teach you
the best real estate course of your life
just come here for a hundred dollars and
then
have someone else do [ __ ] and then have
five more classes i'm like how does
someone believe this [ __ ]
it's all fake obviously i don't get it i
mean someone believes the [ __ ] because
there's i think the biggest problem is
that there's
so much information out there right now
that you don't know who to believe
you don't you just gotta i mean i can
see
when someone knows nothing about yeah i
i know nothing about many things
yeah but i also know when someone's
chatting out of them no no you know what
i mean
you have you have a [ __ ] detective
yeah
a lot of people don't have a 500 pay
wall right out the gate for a lesson is
normally the first indication of
i think to a lot of people you know they
see that pay wall and they see the
presentation they think oh well this is
probably legit yeah i mean i'm putting
money into this so that must be like if
they're paid
if i have to pay this much for this
course then it must bring results yeah
maybe maybe i just can't see that
because obviously we're doing like
entertainment
we've been on the internet for long
enough to know what's going on
we're producing content i know i know
what fake content looks like right i can
imagine how it was made
whenever i see one of those like
marketing um
trailers of like oh you can learn x
amount and earn x amount i swear they
they all have the same [ __ ] templates
and with the same inspiring stock the
first
music i made three thousand dollars the
next month after that
i made one million dollars and it's like
oh i'm sure you did
i'm sure you did off off mugging
everyone off yeah exactly
it's like it's it's like the equivalent
of going on a piracy site and then
seeing the
adverts of i earned ten thousand dollars
from filling out surveys
and you're like who the [ __ ] actually
clicks on this and believes this stuff
it is
the fact that you're advertising on like
not even pornhub or like
some shady hentai website this pill and
your dick will go
three times the size in three months it
must i don't think about it more it must
come from
like targeting insecurities right like
absolutely yeah like
some people are very insecure about
their financial amount yeah like
absolutely i'm sure there's other things
like that i mean i just realized now
why would they offer dick pills oh
because people are pretty insecure about
their dicks back looking right yeah
that's
probably the same kind of yeah and they
probably and they don't know any better
right they just think like well i want
just the quickest easiest like most
straightforward way to get a lot of
money oh look at this ad
it's a harsh lesson in life to learn
that miracles truly donate
yeah yeah i mean i mean it's i'm sure
it's really thought that you need to
actually put that
work and effort into it yeah that might
just be that might be a lifelong yes
i don't think any amount of pills is
going to save you only so many times you
can pop that bag yeah exactly
exactly no i mean i feel like it's the
same reason why people fall for
multi-level marketing scams apparently
this is really bad in the us i have a
lot of friends from the us who tell me
that they know
they've met loads of their friends from
high school who tell them that
constantly message him about it really
yeah yeah yeah i
i don't know how bad it is because i'm
connected to strange people who have
strange friends but
meline do you have friends who are
multi-level marketing people you do
alkaline water all right so you are
live ladies and gentlemen i have one
case my proof is there
i mean yeah i've i know a few people
from america as well
yeah maybe not like directly but you
know people yeah yeah
i know people and even i think sydney's
mom has like
on an off occasion message sydney about
this
you know nice little scheme that can
make him money but
you know seeing the obviously like steps
in and it's because i mean it
it really preys on people who are
looking for that out looking for that
out in their life that you know that you
when you're stuck at a dead-end job
and you are you're old enough where you
feel like
you're you're kind of stuck here you're
not young enough to do something crazy
or just quit everything you have
responsibilities
you know you kind of look for a way that
can
that can that can get you out of this
lifestyle whatever that is and sometimes
i mean that's why
that's why it's that's don't get me
wrong oh i was gonna say like don't get
me wrong like you know
in order to like get out of that kind of
stuff like risk taking is definitely
a thing that you have to do but there's
risk taking there's making mistakes
right
there's there's responsible risk taking
where you'll always have a fallback
if it doesn't work out and then there's
just a risk take where you just yolo it
yeah at the end of the day right the
let's be honest right the way life works
if somebody had
a million dollar idea yeah right a
stranger isn't going to come up to you
and pitch it to you
they're going to [ __ ] do it
themselves yeah exactly right like if
anyone comes up to you promising to make
you money that should be the biggest red
flag
in existence nobody nobody can promise
to make you money yeah yeah for for
example
like if if that person also promising to
make you that money
is a billionaire themselves why the [ __ ]
aren't they doing it yeah exactly
exactly which is when i realized where
like you know when
what i've realized growing up is you
know my my mom and dad would give me you
know advice
about how to be successful in x and why
and i love my mom and dad
but then i came to a point when i
realized that some of the mentality
especially when managing money
was was not wrong per se because that's
what that's the
mentality that they had to survive
because that's the environment it was
just different
yeah it was a different environment i
got to realize i'm growing up under
different circumstances
and i have to you know i have to choose
sometimes whenever
some advice does pertain to me and when
it's when it doesn't and when someone's
promising you to make money that's like
okay we're three successful youtubers
right but as much as and as much advice
as we can give
we cannot promise a random person to
make them a successful youtuber
right we can give advice about how to
increase their chances
and how to you know how to help work the
algorithm for example but we're not
going to drop like a million dollar
video idea because
we would just do that there's no way
there's no way that i can sit here and
guarantee you that yes
i can give you advice to make you a
youtuber that gets a million subscribers
nobody can do that yeah
earn x amount from you as far as i'm
concerned we were all very lucky in that
case as well right we had
we had the we had the odds in our favor
but yeah it was but nobody taught us or
like told us what to do
i mean like i i i preach by that you
know
uh we we did we did a lot of things
right uh and
we all were also very lucky in a lot of
aspects there wasn't there wasn't one
without the other
um there are things that you can do to
increase your chances of success and
massively
get the odds into your favor but to
guarantee something to guarantee success
like that it's
pretty much impossible yeah i think the
the
sad truth of life is that you just
realize this is like i think the stock
market looks like a [ __ ] casino too
many people and
i thought it was a lot a lot of the
hedge funds do treat it like such yeah
exactly
we learned that today at the end of the
day
it's truly a sad moment when you realize
there isn't really a get-rich-quick
scheme
in life it doesn't exist right and like
if you're looking for that i feel like
you're already setting yourself up to be
disappointed or organized if there was a
scheme that could 100
give you like a success rate of like
you're gonna get famous
you wouldn't think everybody would be
doing that it might make someone rich
probably not gonna be you
yeah okay like here's the thing like
dude like reading up
about a lot of like financial advice and
everything that i have for
the past you know the past week so this
is this is like take this with an exact
same three people who don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about financial
discuss financially
yeah exactly okay we do not take any of
our advice yeah
we do have to make a disclaimer about
this but from what i've read and from
what i've seen it's it seems like
you know you you can definitely increase
your chances of you know
being successful in life but the problem
is that a lot of
a lot of the i love the legitimate
advice i've seen
it it seems to stem from uh you don't
get rich quick it's all boring stuff
it's all put your money in safe places
it's the longest wait ten
wait 10 to 20 years and you'll be well
off in life and nobody wants to hear
that advice that's just
boring that shit's boring but you
you don't want to hear about [ __ ]
roth iras or put your put your money in
the [ __ ] cash i want a game stop oh
my games
yeah exactly they want to hear something
exciting but when you hear like
boring financial advice you just kind of
tune out and you're like oh okay so
i can get rich but just not now but like
in
10 20 no no more like when i retire i'm
gonna have a retirement fund
unless god figured out why all the old
people hold all the wealth in nearly
every
developed country yeah why because i
noticed right when i was i was just
looking around for maybe like i wanted
to just talk to about financial advisors
not like do anything
i just wanted to talk to them yeah and
just have like the free consultations
and talk to them just figure out what
the [ __ ] like what do they do what can
they do what's a good one with a bad one
yeah and i noticed on all of the
websites at least in the uk every single
one
right was just like it was picture of
some some young man
helping an old person out on a laptop
pointing at the monitor like
and then it was all stalking yeah it was
it was like oh it was
all just like pension advice pension
pension pension and like
long term long term like none of it was
like risky
yeah none of it was for young people
because yeah because you know let's be
honest
young people don't don't do that don't
do that no no
um so yeah it was just it was really you
kind of just like a lot of the things
that you'd noticed about the world
started to fall in place when you start
looking you're like
yeah ah okay everything's starting to
make sense now yeah yeah
right yeah like my best advice to anyone
young watching this
is um if if this conversation leads to
anything just
go out and do your research actually
read up about this [ __ ] because i i
don't [ __ ] sign up to a 500
no i will [ __ ] i will disown you
don't don't do that just read up
about basic financial advice everything
you need to know is free every yeah
that's the thing everything you need to
know is free and the only thing stopping
you
is your own laziness because that's that
is me reading
me reading up about this felt like i had
just gained five levels of
of info that i should have known when i
was in my twenties and i'm just like why
why didn't i know this [ __ ] before i i
was stupid i was lazy
and yeah don't don't expect to get rich
off the [ __ ] gamestop stonks and sure
they're like
the road is going to be long and
probably really boring yeah i'm
interesting and learning japanese so
that i can become a translator for
for yakuza and then i'll translate the
wrong number liking the great pretender
and profit
hundreds of millions of dollars for
myself thus being the best investment
of ever or someone's going to take that
plan
[ __ ] steal my rich quick idea i swear
to god you gave away the million-dollar
idea bilingual people don't do it all
right
yeah i'm just like writing it
well boys i have something very special
planned today okay they said it wouldn't
happen
the comments said it couldn't be done
but i finally did it i wrote
a powerpoint presentation for all you
actually did it you actually did 20
weeks ago was that this was like a week
like
10 years like episode like nine months
and i was like what just that was just
like
you know you know when you say something
offhand and then it was an offhand
comment
yeah it was an offhand uncommon and then
the community and the reddit would just
like never let you forget that you said
that one thing
to explain what ghana's talking about i
don't know which episode it was play the
flashback mood on what i gotta do is i
gotta
some episode i need to bring a
presentation of all the different ways
people have tried to hit on
[Music]
the most interesting ways it's happening
so i i thought i made a little
presentation with a fun little some fun
images
to explain all the different ways that
you can be so i guess i should pull the
laptop up so
are you gonna are you about to break
down the 93 percent right 93
it's not the 93 anymore it's like 50 50.
this is how you can also be the 93
sign up first month is a hundred dollars
i want to preface this is not my laptop
because it has stickers on it so
yeah this is my beautiful lap youtube
guide to being hit on
all the way oh my god wow this is
bringing me back to like high school
dude you're you're okay you've already
done a powerful presentation
i did i did so is this your ted talk
this is my ted talk
ted didn't invite me so i thought okay
before we start how much effort did you
put into this not that much
so this is like okay so basically i
these are all true things that have
happened at one point or another um
and i i didn't write all the whole
details out so basically
they're more prompt to for my memory to
be like oh yeah this is what happened
all right let me explain it's like a
real ted talk
i guess so yeah this isn't like the high
school i'm reading off the powerpoint
there's literally like two sentences
just to remind me wow oh it's this story
okay
um but yeah i do i do want to preface
before we begin um
i'm not trying to make out that i'm some
kind of like [ __ ] sex
god that can no one can res it's
literally just
when you have x amount of subscribers
obviously there's going to be two people
out there that are stupid enough to
think that i'm attractive and try and
hit on me
right okay you're being very humble
there i do not
i am like ex hot or whatever this just
happens with the job i think
people don't try it with you because you
know you guys are basically married all
right
not to each other of course yeah
why are you laughing melee bailey's like
i love the gay talk
all right so tell me more about how they
married what do you expect to see on
this list
uh exciteful god just i don't know
basically i'm just looking forward to
this presentation just being a massive
excuse to say i'm not a fuckboy bar
yeah no no no you know you know
obviously didn't reciprocate you know
but because most of these are strange
i've also accompanied uh i just
downloaded a bunch of stock images
i didn't pay i didn't i didn't pay for
the license i shouldn't say that but i
just downloaded the bunch still
thank you thank you getty images so
that could just accompany it just for
fun okay actually i love stuff so
we have the classic to start with what
is that
so this is as i've said a text to my
personal number okay what how did they
get your personal number that's what i
want to know gone i don't know
so this happened about i think four or
five months into my youtube
career if you will yeah i thought great
i haven't leaked anything
2015. yeah i was wondering how the [ __ ]
someone had done this yeah yeah um so it
turned out at the time
i had an iphone and the email that i
listed
was actually like my email link to my
iphone account
right and someone had just connected the
dots of like oh i should put
this email in my iphone text connor
don't use iphone anymore oh
that's how because they didn't they did
they did the imessage thing
right right so i deleted that email so
yeah it doesn't exist immediately yeah
because i was like [ __ ] this but
at the time it was very creepy to wake
up to a text from an american number
being like
hi is this connor by the way it's not
exactly being hit on but
stopped it before it could get there
yeah that's the first one i think it's a
stock image
i've actually had something similar
happened to me admire my stuff i have a
lot of questions about the stocking
why is there a potato there what is that
stock image i don't know these are all
strange stock images so
she's just saying no to the potato but
like yeah i
i've had something i've had similar
things happen to me where i'm not gonna
name
what uh messaging app or whatever it was
on but uh
like i've realized that you could find
my username
obviously pretty easily through this
messaging app and i i would get like
people adding me and just messaging me
randomly on it and then
and that that that was that was a humble
experience to realize oh okay i can't
just
yeah i [ __ ] up i can't use this email
for everything now
all right the classy the fan mail the
actual
handwritten letter oh oh like physical
okay is this essentially your p.o box
this was sent to my po box okay
i was about to ask how they found your
address yeah p.o box you know
had a you know had a few letters that
were asking if i was you know
because they would know what conventions
i'm going to and then they would say hey
is it possible that maybe we could you
know go on a date or something
and obviously you know i never got that
even when i was single
no no what uh maybe the times have
changed joey yeah but
youtubers weren't cool back then you
know right this is like two three years
ago this used to happen it didn't happen
that often
but like people would attach their
numbers and like and they never
i mean by the time when i first started
really blowing up on the anime community
i was already
pretty much dating sydney oh yeah and
you know if if
like sydney makes a let's see she marks
the territory
she wards off the laser
on a and then this one is the modern the
fan email obviously you get emails okay
yeah we still get that
classic you know you can get that
classic yeah
um and then this is the the stock image
because this is me putting the emails in
the trash
uh when you send them to me this is all
the fan mails we get for trash taste
i hate you it's not funny all pretty
standard so far for youtubers
yeah yeah yeah okay okay next we have uh
the the
extra classy i would have a i used to do
patreon fan letters
where you could pay to be pen pals with
me okay that sounds
like that doesn't sound like a nightmare
is about to happen that
when i made that i didn't think it was
gonna so it's not on there anymore but
it used to i used to think that it was
like oh this is such a cool way to
connect with me
yeah and i didn't realize about like the
logistics yeah yeah because you never do
with patreon you never think about the
logistics until you realize
oh i have to do this every month yeah
basically i agreed to write like 20
letters
a month which uh i'm not good at writing
either and i don't like writing yeah so
writing one
one letter for me takes like 30 minutes
i've seen it i've seen your handwriting
so it's not
writing so much so it was just painful
and
it was really frustrating as well sorry
i'll go on to have got hit
after but it was frustrating as well
because like people would join patreon
for like one month and leave so i would
send out a letter
that would just be like hi how are you
nice to meet you tell me about yourself
and then not get a response but i'd have
to write
but i'd have to write like seven of
those letters a month yeah every month
and i was like doing them all by hand
how how long was the letter itself uh
like a page or two
jesus jeez that's a long for how much a
month i think it was on like the 40
tier but that was included with the
voicemail so like how much how much
would uh
let's let's break this down cost to
effort-wise how much would it take you
too long write a letter not long
i mean i guess if they paid 40 dollars
for 30 minutes worth of work but
i always get distracted and i couldn't
focus because i just didn't want to be
doing it
yeah right so it was awful but yeah i
had i had someone as well
same same with a fan letter who was like
um
they like it was this really weird
situation where i'm not really sure what
happened
because i was just being like ah yeah
cool i like pokemon too
i like these things because i would try
and be honest and try and make a
friendship with them
yeah and then they were like they
replied one time being like oh
yeah so i told my my co-workers at work
that i have a boyfriend and i said it
was you
and i was like and then they asked like
is that okay and i was like
uh sure i don't give a [ __ ] like i'm not
gonna go wrong i'm not gonna go around
saying that
you can say that like she she
she brings up the sea dog va youtubers
that's amazing
she's like you wanna see my boyfriend my
boy look at that guy
sebastian he's he's his name's sebastian
i'm just thinking
i'm like is that a brag because if they
pull up my videos half of them is either
going to be me reading bl
or me uh in the cosplay yeah and i think
i think they were from like midwest
somewhere
it's a very conservative state so i
couldn't imagine they would take too
kindly to
me being like naked in my room basically
going ah you know like
so yeah that was interesting that was
fun um also it's a boyfriend that never
like [ __ ] responds to like
messages already it's a boyfriend this
is a one-way boyfriend boyfriend that
yeah that replies uh
once a month via mail yeah but yeah i
ended up getting rid of that because uh
yeah just stuff like that sounds like
effort yeah and also just way too much
effort and this is the stock image to
accompany it
oh what is that
this is this was this is me writing the
reply email to the hitman that they
hired if i didn't say yes they were
dating and then yeah this is
the obvious this is called nutting
during fan courses i've popped i made a
video about this you can watch it yeah
yeah it's really old now
i i know the story but yeah so
essentially there was this time
where i was doing uh fan call as hetalia
characters
where she sounds like cringe already
yeah so i was doing it i was doing it
with someone else who was doing another
voice
and we were on the call with the person
and i thought
like there's some weird breathing sounds
coming from them but like
i was like huh this sounds a little
weird but i didn't think much of it
wasn't melon
you bring a ducky mackerel of someone
from like vampires
so like yes so like what happened was
that we were on this call i thought
that's weird then when we got off the
call it was only like
six seven minutes all right i was like
was that was that weird that call was
weird
right yeah like oh no i don't i don't
think so but i was editing the audio
yeah so i go back and listen to the
audio
and i'm like she's definitely nothing
that ain't like that isn't like
that isn't like hyperventilating breath
that is like it was like slow
deep breaths
[Applause]
like that and i was like what the [ __ ]
so i made a video about it but i i pitch
shift it and changed it and it sounds
even creepier
it sounds like a two-year-old scary yeah
because i wanted to protect their
you know particular identity obviously
because right i don't know if it was i
don't know if it wasn't but like
yeah we don't say it don't sound good
yeah yeah yeah but yeah there's all
that i had cut a lot of people oh that's
a bit of yikes there yeah
how did you handle that you just you're
playing character right so
i'm would you when you do those calls
you're in character so like when people
would say stuff
i would reply as if like in character
like to reject them i just i just
like to imagine he's just like you just
hear like
like which italian character were you
playing i was playing france from
italian
but he's like he's like uh i i've never
watched italia
but i assumed he was like a bit of a
player from what i understood but
i would have loved it if he was playing
like italy and he was just like they
were playing
france they were playing yeah they were
playing italy
[Music]
this episode is sponsored by ej anime
store catecho's official online anime
merch store that specializes in
delivering the newest anime merch to
overseas anime fans directly from japan
be sure to check out the pre-order
deadline shown on screen so you don't
miss out on today's item what do we have
for today's items look at all these
beautiful items
look at look at all that man look what
are you holding connor i've recently
just become an art appraiser really
i have to say i've added this piece to
my collection gentlemen because it's a
steel this wonderful piece here as i've
been instructed multiple times to
pronounce correctly by marlene
is sayakano how to raise a boring
girlfriend utaha
kasumi gaoka
[Laughter]
right obviously conor is a massive
sayakana fan with block print now i'm as
a big fan of the show
i gotta say gentlemen yeah following uh
as a big fan of this i have to say
following megumi
and erie is
[Music]
is finally here the wait is over these
are brought to life using japanese
craftsmanship techniques
originating in the 17th century god damn
that is old and the background artwork
is actually connected so all three
illustrations lined up
next to each other form one large
picture
wonderful is that looks beautiful is
that part of the appraisal
it is and we also got the konosuba
megamin anime opening edition
i mean look at how beautiful this is
that's actually one of the dope is
making me feel like i have a couple of
them
of course this is cara annie's new
figure
label ca works bringing you this
beautiful connoisseur figure
portraying mega min unleashing her
explosion magic
while falling from the sky i think you
mean explosion i'm sorry i'm sorry fake
fake connoisseur
jobless reincarnation roxy magurdia
figurine right look at that
which actually looks kind of again she
does look dope love the base right there
we also got the re zero fredrika bauman
tea party version and we've also got the
fake khalid liner prisma ilia miyu
edelfeld's wedding bikini version
that is connor's favorite yeah that is
connor's favorite right yeah you love
that right you love that
well i do love it so i'm gonna go and
check out these items on each
animestore.com while they're still
available
or click the link in the description
below and if you haven't already follow
them on facebook and twitter at ej anime
store so you don't miss their giveaways
and limited time
offers back to the episode whoa yeah and
like
to be fair it would happen fairly often
but i nearly always cut them because it
was just cringe
yeah yeah i just feel like i want to
date about sebastian i'd be like no no
no no one is worthy of me like that i
would like because i don't know why
because because like it's really like
dude when you're because i wear them in
the zone
and i would do these calls like i would
like fully believe in that moment that i
was like that like because
you have to if you want to do it good i
mean you're you're playing a character
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so when people would
say stuff like that i would just like
snarkily just insult them straight away
because they loved it yeah like it was
and it was fun like
everyone dude imagine being an [ __ ] i
was like oh my god he's amazing how long
did you do this for
these calls yeah i did them for like two
three years how is this how
no because when it was when it went well
it was really fun because people had
such a genuine like
happy response great it was just you had
to just deal with some weird [ __ ] that's
fast
fairly often yeah um and so i was like
all right i'm a head out
like this like the stock image uh from
that they're
that cool am i right i'm only joking
melon you and you're probably never that
bad right yeah no no she was
she still is she is worse
i've seen her when she gets around to no
prince all right
next is the uncomfortable as if and none
of them were right yeah right
the last one wasn't uncomfortable uh no
i can deal with that okay because that's
in character yeah
that's sebastian that's france that's
not my fault
that's francis she's getting real hot
for france
um so yeah so i up until very recently i
used to do patreon phone calls and uh
not in character no it's me yeah yeah
yeah so i would offer
and it's gonna sound like a lot for like
a hundred dollars an hour uh to have a
call with me but then if you ask any
youtubers around our size they'll be
like wow that's too little
yeah because it's just i know it sounds
absurd it sounds stupid my parents all
thought it was dumb they were like
people
people pay to speak to you connor that's
absurd
my parents got the same reaction why
would anyone want us to pay to speak to
you connor
like mum [ __ ] off mama um so anyway up
until recently i used to do patreon
phone calls like
like i said uh i would have like i'd
call it like generations i don't really
know why
but people would always leave in mess
and join a mess and there was only 10
spots on
my course so only 10 people at a time
could clear these calls all right um
and i would only maybe have like one
person who was on it for like two plus
years
but the rest of the time is like
rotating people and like
i had some really [ __ ] uncomfortable
ones that i haven't really spoke about
because i'm just like this is so [ __ ]
weird but i mean this will speak about
it now
yeah so this is one time this is by far
the most uncomfortable
um where i'd done two calls to the
person and they were like okay they were
like oh
all right they seem pretty decent seem
pretty normal they're from from vegas
you know
okay represent yeah i don't know why
you're pointing at me
and uh they were like i'm sorry i didn't
do webcam it was only ever a voice but
one time they were like can we do webcam
and i was like all right sure
i mean what a one-off right like i'll
what
what's the worst that could happen yeah
of course yes yes
you guys know what happened yeah but so
and i'm like okay sure sure let's do it
let's just do webcam whatever
you know you've been you've been on the
patreon for a while we can do this so we
boot up the the call
i turn on my webcam sheet on she turns
on her webcam
uh yeah she's naked she's fully naked
but wearing like body paint but like you
can
like put the look on ash's face
[Music]
immediately i was like yo what the [ __ ]
and then
i was like oh oh no the connection's
breaking up
and then like can you hear me i was like
i was like
gosh i'm going through the tunnel oh
yeah i'm just just literally
literally the moment it happened like it
flashed on the screen i was like smash
the red red
[ __ ] end before i was like [ __ ] man
you know how hard british internet man
it keeps going out
yeah i'm so mad at them man oh i know
i gotta stay on voice you know yeah my
internet can't handle the webinar
my webcam just imploded so i was like
[ __ ] that's awful it wasn't terrible
and i had some other uncomfortable
things come up and yeah generally just
just just not very good things happen
that was just like why why are they
doing this like they were just hit on
you in really uncomfortable ways and
you know and to the point where it was
just like you know some people were
think
would think that you know you would meet
some people
who had clearly never been rejected in
their their their circle right
yeah and that they paid they pay me to
talk to me and then i'm like
well i've never been rejected so it's
it's not going to start now right
they think i'm going to like well i'm
this is a work thing for me i'm there
doing business you know
it sounds like you had a [ __ ] babe
station call center
honestly it's like it's great 90 people
it was chill it was just talking to them
get maybe give them a bit of youtube
advice maybe help them with things
super normal calls it's just like some
people were like bro this is my end
this is my way to get to get like connor
to like hang out with me and
stuff and like i know all sorts of weird
[ __ ] like people would go around and um
like i think recently i used to do like
voice recordings
i still do to be fair yeah they're
really easy but people would go around
take the voice recordings and say look
me and connor are best friends
nah like connor me i have a message from
connor saying hi
to me yeah we're kind of like best
friends and i'm like do people know like
why do people do this why do you think
you're getting clout are you comfortable
with that
that's whatever i wouldn't be
comfortable i would not be comfortable i
don't know
that that that's me someone going around
saying that their friend of mine to like
get their way is like not good yeah
i mean it's it's also you know it's big
brain because you know i could be like
any time i let's say right god forbid i
say something stupid on a live stream
we're like no no that's just recording
it just recording
it patreon recording not me no
mean yeah i i never i never recorded
anything inappropriate yeah it's just
like
obviously because some people want like
a uh an uplifting message
down recently and i'm more than happy to
do that because i'm like you know if me
giving you a voice message saying hey
man just just
you know things will get better just
just keep trying i mean i've i've done
that before as well but
at the same time if i found out that
that person oh my god i don't like the
voice of messages anymore yeah what was
going on telling people hey
i'm best friends with giggling i'm
impressed friends we've gone and i'm
just like okay
get the [ __ ] out of my life please i
mean that's right
i emailed them basically saying hey uh
yeah yeah
i'm removing you from patreon what the
[ __ ] you doing this is sad
like yeah like oh yeah of course that's
not cool because
it wasn't the worst thing was that she
wasn't going around to like her close
friends for some reason she was going
around sending them to other youtubers
oh saying i'm friends with connor look i
have this message and
unfortunately some of those youtubers
didn't know that i was doing the patreon
but i mean i i've gone through that as
well where i've had people going around
saying that they know me and saying that
they it happens
i've been friends with me when they
weren't just to try and get in with
other people
and yeah it's like that's that's the
biggest [ __ ] red flag for me but
that's why i
that's kind of one of the big reasons as
well as time is why i removed the
ability to call me on patreon i don't do
it anymore you can't have a
phone call with me i mean i i think the
worst thing that happened to me was it
literally happened to me at a convention
where you know i had a guy who was going
around telling people
telling companies that they knew me and
that that they they were trying to use
that as an inn that's
that's that's somehow even worse isn't
that when they're going around to like
because they're potentially ruining your
name yeah yeah exactly but they're also
trying to profit themselves yeah
i can deal with someone being a [ __ ]
creep i could that's that's insular i
can i can i can just immediately shut
that down
right someone does that that's repairing
i have to do yeah yeah that's horrible
yeah yeah yeah luckily
you know that's i guess that's why it
triggers me so much because i i hear
that i'm just i just think
too like the [ __ ]
i would gladly have someone hit on me on
a call a hundred times
rather than them go to a company saying
that we're friends yeah you know what i
mean because i can you know that's fine
don't do that
do not do that that is the biggest
[ __ ] move you could do we have gone
in uh
50 years it's egg
i don't know what the stock image is
what the [ __ ] did you get this
image from i don't know what is this
like asian humpty dumpty
you type in egg okay
um so um this is the real i was at a
coffee shop one time
good old swansea and uh i recently
just broke up with my ex-girlfriend at
the time i was very sad and so my
housemate took me out for coffee
right and we were just like you know he
just wanted to talk to me and just you
know keep me
up uplifted you know and i love coffee i
love talking so
this is a perfect combination right and
whilst i was at the coffee shop dressed
in like sweatpants
miserable i some person some what looked
to be like a 15 year old girl i [ __ ] you
not
this is by the way i was like i was like
20 comes up to me and i know they're
coming to me
you know how i know they've got a
[ __ ] they have like the the scout
leader scout regiment
backpack from attack on titan and i i
saw
i saw them looking at me i could see
this eye contact not breaking coming up
to me right
and no joke right she was like can i sit
down and join you for coffee
and and she's like 15. and her friend is
like right there and i'm like what is
happening
uh i think that's like kind of
inappropriate like i don't really know
you
i really want to do this i mean it's not
really being hit on because underage but
like
yeah it was just kind of uncomfortable
and just like what
i thought like a picture sure okay i'm
totally fine with doing pictures or
signing anything you want i don't care
about that but like
you just sit down and start talking
don't invite yourself to like that
yeah yeah yeah i don't know it's weird
but they're a kid they didn't know any
better yeah
i mean that's happened to us a few times
i would i would think it's happening
conventions quite a bit yeah it happens
like conventions
i expect it but like we're going outside
just chilling and i was i was pretty
beat up at the time and i was really
yeah
a girl come up to me just being like hey
can i sit next to you i'm like
i really don't want to do right now i
don't want to do anything with any women
anymore
it was literally like the day off as
well i was like i was like miserable
yeah well because i think i think about
i think about that and i think you know
she'll probably look back at that period
of crash and just [ __ ] cringe
yeah because like i can i can like not
not i'm not saying i'm not saying you're
not saying you should do it i'm not
saying
you know i'm justifying her anything
because you shouldn't do that but
i i know that you know when when you're
that young
and you feel like you have a parasocial
relationship you don't you don't know
about this stuff
especially you don't know about you know
the social boundaries and she'll
probably grow up and
she'll look back at that and she'll wake
up in a cold sweat
and think why the [ __ ] did i do it
literally you can approach me
anywhere i don't even even if it's in a
[ __ ] toilet i don't really give a
[ __ ]
just as long as i'm not pissing yeah or
i'm eating or drinking yeah
please please don't do it when i'm
pissing while i'm pissing and eating
just please don't like
because i just want to finish my meal
it's what i look forward to most of the
time
where we can have like full privacy so
just give us that price
not even that i just want to enjoy my
meal you know i just love food so much
i i don't have to think about oh [ __ ] i
got to take a picture of my steak's
going cold
yeah but yeah no and this is the stock
image to go along with
this coffee shop now i
i had i had a you know i told you a
story about it i think you know
this is the exact face you made when you
saw me oh joey's like you know it's joe
i'm like
no that's
the next story before but yeah this is
the hotel key card one which is
um did you know actually this is the
same trio
ludwig
that doesn't look like this is my
girlfriend this is the girlfriend this
is the girlfriend meme with the guy
looking the other way
oh i recognize the guy's face it's the
exact same model
from the girlfriend um so yeah to those
who don't know and don't want to go back
and watch the episode essentially what
happened was
uh someone uh gave me a piece of paper
uh and they were like this is for you
and on it was there was the hotel key
card and room number
that was signed and they and it was said
uh there was like times where i could go
right and uh there's a person at the
desk next to me who is helping you know
manage the because when you get the
money you had it to them yeah yeah and
they were like
bro and i'm like do you want it i don't
want it
needless to say i i immediately gave it
to the hotel reception when i was done
signing things yeah
right and they were like why do you have
this and oh my god it's a long story
um and this one's called the bold it's a
hotel door the bowl we're the hotel door
so i told you one story about how um
there was uh one hotel room where i was
on the bottom floor and
we came out and there's the two girls
there at midnight but there's another
time
where i came back and this wasn't as
creepy it was just kind of weird
it was like middle of the day like 1pm
was that an anime convention this was
that
of course it was an outfit where else
would it be
so um i think i don't know how someone
found out is my room i was i was pretty
careful like
i made sure like i sound so [ __ ]
stupid like make sure no one was
following me
right as god should have yeah you know
yeah are you this is why i do it even
though it sounds like
it's
i wouldn't have understood until i got
followed back to my room yeah i just
i just don't want people to know yeah
right like you know um
and there was just like for some reason
like one girl who looked like in her 30s
just like you know how the door frame is
like like this just sitting like like
this in my door frame like blocking the
door
what and i was like well like the door's
here yeah so that's the frame
that's the frame okay and this is the
other frame so they're they're just
there right in front of your door yeah
and i was like
hello and they were like oh i like your
videos
and i'm like i'm like oh no
i'm like social skills 10 000.
i was like oh okay i mean awesome like
you want a picture and they were like
yeah sure that'd be awesome
we took a picture and then they just
left and i was like cool i don't have to
say anything
all right awesome because i was like i
didn't know what was going on i was like
why are you in front of my hotel room
door we're on like
the fifth floor yeah and this is like
nowhere near the elevator or anything
like this is really far away
i think maybe they wanted i don't know
if they knew me uh obviously they did
when i went but my first thought was
like are they just chilling here because
i get it because sometimes the
the lobby is really crowded and [ __ ] you
wanna just go to the the alleyway or
whatever in the [ __ ] room because
they're long
yeah i was just like oh how did you know
this was my door that's really
concerning i wanted to ask her never
found out so to this day i don't know
why she was in front of my door
i don't this isn't a know good guy
getting hit on this is just strange ways
people approach me yeah
it sounds like this this sounds like a
lot of strange things that have happened
about you getting stalked just gonna say
hit on just we're gonna put it all under
the umbrella
this is this is the youtube clickbait
we're gonna say hit on in yeah
this is true and then this is the stock
image that i found for this one
although there is that one script or the
audio only listeners this does make me
realize about the person who isn't on
the list but the person who named
that baby after me have we told that
story
yeah so back in like when i was really
doing black butler a lot there was this
one person
um who oh this is it i remember i just
remember the canonical order in my head
um i went to the black butler meetup the
canonical order
this is head canon they're saying the
filler art
so what happened was i this was like my
first ever ax i can't remember how long
i was doing youtube for but i thought it
would be cool just to go to the black
butler meetup and just like be
like say hi hey man like yeah i'm i'm
the guy on youtube
all the black butler stuff right right
um and just say hi and just you know it
was just just to meet them
and just meet all the fans of black
belter and be like yeah this is [ __ ]
sick and they're all really nice and
there's one person who's like
really really nice super super nice
and um yeah and she was really nice we
got loads of pictures with her and she's
a little intense you know but that's
fine i'm used to that
yeah i mean all black butler fans are
quite intense yeah yeah yeah but like
some of them are like some of them are
just there don't give a [ __ ] about you
know like
like watching my videos but there was a
good i'd say like half there were like
oh my god
because you're the black butler guy back
then well yeah i mean i i says of
youtube i was the only one making
content about black butler
because it was like how many years after
black butler dead and yeah i feel like i
almost made like a mini like renaissance
of the fact yeah yeah yeah
in terms of western yeah um because it's
like the community
became way more active and like kind of
like what
uh the abridged series did for the
yu-gi-oh anime back in the day i mean i
i don't want to say it was like no not
heavy but like i feel like it was
definitely a bump because of all the
black
stuff i was pumped yeah yeah the stuff
but anyway so
a year goes by right and i go to the you
know they're they're
messaging me telling me oh you have to
come back to the blackboard let me up
again i have a big surprise for you
and so i'm like all right okay sure i
thought it was like a gift or something
they're making it out to be yes i was
like okay sure i'll get it i'll take a
picture
i'll come why not this is the point
where i'm trying to distance myself from
black butler
i was like okay cool i'll i'll come and
so i go
uh yeah lord behold she's holding a baby
like literally like two month old baby i
don't know how old this baby is
fresh fresh baby fresh baby fresh out
the oven fresh
freshly made baby single wrinkle on this
baby
and she's like oh do you want to hold
connor
i'm like connor i'm like oh that's a
funny coincidence
i said oh no no it's not a coincidence i
named him after you and i'm like
okay this is [ __ ] weird this is
[ __ ]
weird my favorite ever photo is of you
holding baby connor with the most
uncomfortable smile i've ever seen
how did you even react to that uh just
pure confusion and
again you got an insane gun i just go
with everything his face all the babies
like
i mean i would do exactly the same thing
i wanted the picture to reflect like how
uncomfortable i was yeah so that i could
i could like tell the story later on
now yes there's a picture out there if
you just google connor with baby maybe i
don't [ __ ] know what's going on with
baby
dog baby well i don't know what the [ __ ]
comes up
c dog v82 too fat this baby was [ __ ]
cute
yeah but like there's something wholly
uncomfortable about holding a stranger's
baby that i just
i don't know it's like holding someone's
expensive vars you know it's like
i still don't know how to handle babies
like someone asked me if i want to hold
if i want to hold their baby and i'm
just like does it come with an
instruction manual
what do i do like i i feel so inadequate
when it comes to handling babies they're
great for the 10 seconds where they're
not
like crying and then the moment you pick
them up and they start crying i'm like
oh god oh god
what what do you think please please
stop yeah but like
you know as as odd as that is and and
almost creepy you could say yeah yeah i
mean
it's flattering more than anything i
guess but it was i mean don't get me
wrong they were very nice it's probably
flattering
in a sense it's flattering i just i i
would feel that if anyone named a baby
after me that's a bit that's a bit
too much pressure on me i feel like
naming your baby after any influencer is
a bad idea did you find them mainly
what did you type in
okay then found it by typing in c dog
baby apparently it comes off i just
think it's a bad idea
naming your your baby after any
influencer yeah we all know we're just
one bad team
yeah don't name your kid after your
family it's like it's like it's like
getting a tattoo but
yeah favorite but youtuber luckily
luckily
it was just connor and not c dog v8 yeah
yeah yeah that would like it i i have
i have like no idea how corpse husband
feels whenever
when he sees like his voice like what
what would you call it
his wave file yeah of him
breathing as a tattoo i'm just like man
how did you handle that
yeah um yeah so that was
that's how that happens yeah that is
very bold indeed that is very bold
uh i've got i've got like the next one
it's called the smooth paper
i've been handed uh pieces of paper
before just at conventions you know i'll
do i'll just like sign something or i'll
i'll take a picture and i'll show me a
piece of paper
right i'll be like hey here's my number
come text me i think that's kind of
smooth
that's very old stuff i don't know why
that's smooth i never replied to any of
them because i'm like bro
my phone doesn't work in the u.s sorry i
just have the internet but
it's very smooth i like it i actually
like that one i think it's classy now
now you're going to get this every
conversation because it's like it's like
with this one
it's like it's not intense it's like i i
if i want to call you i'll call you i'm
not gonna call you just letting you know
because i'm too [ __ ] just the casual
right that's that's how i imagine people
yeah there's something simple about it
that's so inoffensive
but maybe it's because i'm a guy i feel
like if i was a girl and guys kept doing
it to me i'd be like annoyed yeah that'd
be very creepy
yeah i kind of like it it's very
flattering when someone is
attractive and they send you you know
they hit on you it's like oh wow
this league really oh no get out of here
i thought
we weren't even playing the same sport
dude i thought i was playing checkers
you're playing 4d
chess this don't match but yeah i mean
you know i mean it's a nice ego boost
for like 20 minutes until you realize
that like
he realizes a bit weird yeah he realized
that's a bit strange golden rule don't
[ __ ] your fans right
yeah exactly especially in this climate
i i just think that's like oh yeah
stick by honestly yeah dude whenever i
used to because for the first like
two three months in japan i was using i
i had like tinder because i thought
no one's going to recognize me on tinder
fantastic yeah but yeah those people who
recognize me on tinder here
who could speak english obviously and
then obviously a white guy would stand
out right yeah and they were like oh i
watch your videos i'm like immediately
unmatched
yeah yeah honestly like see you did you
played it smart
was that why would i want to i don't
want to date someone who turns up and
they're like
yo i love that video whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
because i thought unfortunately there's
a lot of youtubers who probably use that
as an ego boost right
i mean okay getting in the whole topic
of [ __ ] your fans or dating your fans
there is a way to go about it there is a
right way and there is
definitely a wrong way like yeah they
they met through being fans
yeah and there was a that no one ever
would question the
the what's the word legitimacy the
legitimacy or
the efficacy of that right that's a
legitimate relationship
but there are ways doing it that that it
like taking advantage of your power and
i think that's why people have the
problem
yeah and unfortunately a lot of
youtubers don't understand when they are
just kind of taking advantage of their
own power yeah in the situation yeah i i
feel i feel like
like hooking up like i say hooking up
hooking up with the wrong words
because if hooking up with your fans
implies that yeah you you are just kind
of just like
you're not doing anything you're just
kind of throwing throwing your
fame out there and everything like that
yeah and i feel like you have to be
really self-conscious about this and i'm
glad that
people are like looking more into this
and like i'm like put putting more
attention
getting smarter about it yeah and fans
are getting smarter about this as well
as they really should be
um and it's the responsibility you hold
as a youtuber
and sometimes you just don't want to
worry about that you just want to meet
someone where you don't want to have to
worry about this power imbalance because
you you are you know we're all just
people as well we're all just people and
sometimes we just want to
switch off this part of our lives and
just be a normal [ __ ] person like
anyone else
um yeah i don't want someone who's
watches my videos and has an expectation
of me in general that i can from that is
portrayed through right
right it's funny because most of the
friends i've made
who started off as fans like as we
became
friends they just started watching less
and less of my stuff and because that's
because
that's that in a lot of the ways that
made me more comfortable or they we
stopped talking about it because
they were just mates and we would talk
like mates and talk about
whatever else apart from my job as i'm
sure that
i kind of feel that works in the same
way with like friends between two
youtubers right
yeah i definitely like watch like less
of like my
youtuber friends videos after we just
kind of went
past that point just became friends no
you you keep up with it just just to see
what your mates are doing yeah yeah yeah
but you're not like damn bro that last
video [ __ ] banger bro like i would
have done this differently
yeah like i showed i like showing sports
my mates you know yeah
it's different from being like yo i'm a
huge fan of what you did
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] banger right there yeah
yeah it's
man life's hard if you're you should
if you want to just be safe don't [ __ ]
your face rule number one
working good for me yeah yeah oh my god
uh this is my stock image can you
explain
why you chose this one okay so there is
a labrador
with a gun holding her i just thought
this one was fun you know
okay sure i don't know it's kind of fun
this is what happens when you
reach like the end of your project and
you just like i'll just throw whatever
[ __ ] i put up oh we're about halfway
we're about halfway okay okay the next
one start getting a bit more obviously
okay uh you've been hit on the youtube
comment section of course
yeah of course yeah take me on a date
next time i visit japan
that happens yeah that happens a few of
those comments it's like
uh no how about how about you pay for my
date yeah
i wonder if anyone is ever in the
history of youtube probably has
would have taken a comment like that
seriously and i mean they tried to
pursue it
i mean i mean maybe if you like you're
if you're a smaller youtuber maybe yeah
i mean i i did something similar along
with like email someone emailed me
asking me to go on a date
but there's a
um anyone can write a youtube call
they're live and then obviously you know
people ask you on dates on live streams
all the time you're streaming
yeah i get comments sometimes being like
oh we're on a date and we go in japan or
people people subtly ask questions that
are like
i think that they think they're being
subtle right but it's very obvious what
they're asking
like for example one very big giveaway
as to what some people are asking um are
like hey
uh would you ever do like long distance
relationships by the way just uh
and like some people might genuinely be
curious right but there's like a way
that certain people ask it that is like
uh no no you know it kind of gives you
that vibe of like
you're asking this for a purpose yeah
and also
i get donations sometimes which i think
that's another one actually
but um where people will be like oh um
just like wondering like what kind of
age age group do you go for
uh if it isn't obvious by now uh milfs
so you know you know if you're if you're
around my age lonely housewives
the walls for the next stream is your
husband just not cutting it i don't want
to know who he is but
i'm kidding yeah i mean yeah stuff like
that what else do i get there's ones as
well you know what i get asked a fair
amount which
is like the least subtle which is like
would you ever date someone who like
doesn't do youtube and i'm like would
you think i exclusively date psychopaths
like whatever you think no i only
exclusively date youtubers that's weird
i don't have at least ten thousands you
guys date youtubers but i couldn't
imagine dating a youtuber i mean i
started dating her when she had like
less than a thousand subs so it's a
little bit different i mean i convinced
my girl to become a youtuber yeah
yeah so you brought them into the play
yeah we brought them in yeah i wouldn't
want my significant other to be a
youtuber why
i don't know i don't want to [ __ ]
deal with another me that's [ __ ]
awful
and like my schedule is such a mess
already i wouldn't like a relationship
to me like that would be such a [ __ ]
mess if both of us had similar schedules
like that i mean i don't blame you
there's lots of people who are like that
i mean
that's just me i mean that's just what i
want yeah i feel like that's just how
our relationships ended up
yeah yeah true true it's just a standard
word schedule and like this
stock image which is uh
again it doesn't really have anything to
do with the point but it's a funny story
i just wanted to put a stock integer in
there yeah this one uh donations again
um this is the charitable i'm pretty
sure these are called simps right yeah
yeah these are called uh yeah yeah you
can't say that anymore oh yeah
off twitter no i don't call them prime
members
tier three subs are you a prime member
well we're going on a date soon
uh yeah obviously you get that a lot
actually instagram
message requests get that a lot yeah you
actually check them
no i don't i know every now and then
just because i used to i used to
yeah i used to as well and then i
realized that these are useless and like
yeah yeah stop checking it you would
people just it's like throwing a coin
down a while hoping for to grow it into
a tree
right it's like it's not gonna happen um
but yeah this is the stock image to go
along with it
i don't really know what is happening
they're on a carb on it yeah
and definitely having sex i'm not really
sure it's going no idea what's going on
there
yeah so that's that seems instagram
messages completely useless don't do it
it's not gonna work
um unless you have a [ __ ] ton of
followers i think it pops up and the
instagram tells you
yeah yeah yeah someone begs me there's
like some kind of threshold
yeah it's like having that blue tick
mark on
twitter already mentioned this one but
uh just just
uh tinder yeah i mean
wait is that the is that the same girl
the
in front of the burning house it does
look like it looks like her doesn't it
oh yeah it kind of does yeah could be it
could maybe she found a
nice career in stock images afterwards
that who knows
uh also actually believe it or not i've
been here on fiverr but
of course you have no joke no of course
you know
why am i not surprised
i've got a great deal for you let me
give you a custom offer on fiverr
all right so yeah actually funny enough
they already they're a really good sport
about it though but they were basically
just kind of like
um i think i had hired them for one of
the videos i think they were an artist
what what were they uh what were they
trying to buy from you
no no so i hired them yeah and then when
the video came
out they were like oh thanks for
including me in the video bye i don't
know
if you like want to ever like just call
or hang out
here's my discord and i'm like oh okay
all right okay
this man's an absolute chick magnet no
no this is what i'm saying right when
when you have you know you get how many
[ __ ] views we get a month on our own
chat like
eight nine million views a month right
all it takes is one person to think i'm
attractive
why i don't know to then go on and then
do something right i don't think
i'm inherently more attractive than
anyone or most people yeah but the thing
is
that like you should have a platform
like right but the thing is that like
i've never experienced i don't think
gonzo experienced that
really well not not to this but then i
also i i
also i also but also like i feel like
your content
yeah i do videos about like dating and
stuff yeah yeah i mean i mean like
it doesn't surprise me because you do
more appeal more to that kind of thing
and any any anyone who
like has because a lot of your content
base started off with literal fan
interaction
yeah yeah for me i did i literally
didn't start
like even for most of my videos i don't
show my face on like yeah
whereas we don't give a [ __ ] about us
my whole youtube like career in the show
which built off interaction and i'm very
grateful right which is why like it
doesn't surprise me why some of the
weirdest fan interactions have
come from come from you i guess so yeah
that makes sense if you give avenues for
people to talk to you they'll find a way
to hit on you that's how it works
and this is the stock image oh my god
what is that that was me at the end of
the figurine like
true true truth that's what it felt like
that's what it felt like
what the direction was here i'm curious
hey kids swallow this fish for us real
quick
all right gotcha viking kids
how much you're getting five dollars for
this all right uh next time i've
i've been asked out if i'd like to go
drinking with someone at a panel
uh i've had in front of other people in
front of the whole panel yeah i've had
that
like uh two two women who are yeah i
guess
in my in my preferred demographic of you
know older women
yeah like would you like
listening i was like goes through his
analytics and he picks by demographic
he's just like
get rid of all this this is like 25 to
30. no
none of that too close 25 to 45 though
oh
okay so legit i think it was uh
there there's two two women right uh
they were i think
one was the aunt and one was the mother
of the door they brought along and
she just sticks her hand up and she's
like i have no idea who you are but i
like your voice would you be willing to
have drinks with us later the mom said
that the mum said that and
i've never seen a child go from like
smiling to anger so fast
the child was like mom mom
i was like i was gonna say that i was
just like yeah i'd love to like laugh
like jokingly never did i actually if
honestly if they came up to me
afterwards or found me at the bar i'd
have been like
okay i love talking i don't know mums
are so fun to talk to anime conventions
no not in the hitting on way just just
in general they're so fun dude because
they don't give a [ __ ] and they're like
i don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
but i'm the cool parent
to be fair yeah to be fair when like if
it's at a signing and like a mom or a
dad comes with their son or daughter
they're always so chill and they're like
yeah they're the best people honestly
they
they are pretty chill yeah they are
bailey's trying to make it creepy it's
not [ __ ] creepy
it's it's it's it's because you
specifically said moms yeah
like i love talking to parents at
conventions because i'm just like dad
okay give me all the moms no no no no
i've had like uh
wait i don't know if it comes up later
i'll i'll tell you later but basically
there's
one guy i've had before like his kids
really like me he was like oh yeah can i
buy you dinner or something i'm like oh
[ __ ] sure why not
yeah yeah we'll hang out be nice and it
was nice getting to know him and his
kids so that's cool
yeah i've had the same things with like
dads as well yeah they just
you know if if a dad's willing to like
get involved in this [ __ ] then they're a
cool [ __ ] dad yeah because i
absolutely you know when when that
happens and they they they show
passion about like what their kids
passionate about right
i think they're so [ __ ] cool that's a
good parent i wish my parents did that
because my parents didn't do that i
would never do that to this day
i i think the proudest mom i've ever uh
seen was
it was that it was at ax and you know we
had signings uh signings and then
uh two little kids come and you know
they were queuing stuff and then
the mum looks at me and she like sees my
name
and everything and she goes ask me in
thai are you thai
and then i i reply inside and then we
have this conversation and she was just
like
i am so [ __ ] happy that my kids are
looking up to a thai person
thank you for representing the thai
people i am proud of you thank you very
much
i had the opposite once in finland where
the mum was a big fan and the daughter
like the mom came up was like god i wish
that was me
so can you sign this and i was like yeah
sure and i looked at the daughter and i
was like okay
you know like what's your name i looked
at the door i was like what's your name
and the mom was like no no no it's me
and i was like oh okay oh okay because i
i feel like
for like southeast asian parents right
we any anytime you talk to a southeast
asian parent whenever
you meet someone else usually the same
race every southeast asian mother
especially they go into southeast asian
mum mode right so the first thing she
legit asks me
after finding out i'm thai and just you
know asking the basic questions is
um have you had any thai food recently
because i can i can i got a good time
you gotta have good thai food you know i
i could recommend you some places if
you're missing some thai food i'm just
like
dude i honestly i'm like thank you so
much i'm going to take this advice to
heart because honestly
and awesome honestly yes i am missing
thai food
i am missing home because i also like
mums or like parents have come up to me
and like do you want to water you look
like you're like
tired yeah yeah thank you i'll take this
oh thank you that's so kind i've had
like a dad like just slit me at 20 being
like buy yourself a beer after this man
you're working
you're working real hard today son i'm
like oh thanks man
i i had one one time similar to that but
uh there was a
actually an old patriot of mine uh met
me and uh her grandma came and she
must've been like
70-80 and she was just so impressed that
i wrote in cursive
she was like she was like like in like
the most like hick like not here it was
kind of like midwestern
kind of like oh you know it's just not
right they they teach the kids here they
don't teach them how to write cursive
it's not right i really like that you
keep the old ways alive and i'm like
because i'm just british
i've never [ __ ] clawed you guys today
i don't know if it's that good because
no one can read my [ __ ] handwriting
yeah i mean honestly
what are your kids doing it's probably
pretty pretty good actually
yeah i also stock image i actually found
one that was fitting for this
[Laughter]
pregnant lady with a gun with a gun with
a tiniest gun i've ever seen
that's like a that's like that's like a
bb gun that's like a a german pistol
like world war ii that looks like
well that's like the spike hide in a
post is this a scene from like in
glorious bastards or something like
this is definitely a frame taken from a
quentin county yeah yeah yeah
um [ __ ] oh yeah yeah this was
this wasn't so much uh odd this wasn't
being hit on but this is just a funny
story i wanted to tell
you so uh one time uh there was uh i was
at a convention
and i actually had this guy on facebook
still so it was really nice but it was
just it was very strange
and things get added on and adding on
where i went to it and they were like
okay so you when you go to convention as
a guest
you typically if it's like a big
convention you'll get like a handler
like it's like an assistant yeah
basically someone who makes sure that
you turn up to your appointments on time
and also if you need anything or like
you say you're signing things
and you you know you run out of sharpies
like give me a shop real quick
uh they'll do stuff like that and um uh
the guy i had he was like oh yeah my
daughter's a big fan
i'm like oh cool cool that's that's
awesome would you mind like saying hi to
her and i'm like yeah of course of
course like i'll hang out with them yeah
and then he was really nice and he
helped me out a lot he always got me
whatever i needed
and then uh he was like yeah do you want
to like come for like a
family dinner with me and my family
would say oh okay
uh i mean i i felt like i had to say yes
but like i was like oh sure i mean of
course like i don't mind i mean this
guy's helping you out right yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean i literally had
nothing better than you i was like yeah
sure why not
real nice so yeah i'd love to meet your
family his family was like
12 kids or something jesus christ and
like half of them half of them knew who
i was and half of them didn't care
yeah it was like it was like being in
the middle of a half a dozen what's that
movie called like does it
double does what the [ __ ] is that i i
know what you're talking about
i was like by the dozen or something
something like that yeah but it was
really cool because i i think i think he
was like a foster parent or something
and it was really cool the story was
really unique
not being hit on by the way quite the
opposite just thought it was a cool
story to tell
so it was really odd that i got like
roped into this and i was like what is
happening
why is there 12 kids i thought all i can
envision is the
scene from annie where they're they're
all like eating on the real
table you're just in the middle like
yeah i'm in the middle of it
i felt bad because the dad was trying to
talk to me but obviously all the kids
were like yeah it's a youtuber they
wanted my attention
they kept asking me questions and they'd
be like do you pay taxes or something
like that
are you avoiding taxes are you the irs
yeah it was it was just pretty cool
about that was a fun story yeah um
oh god why wow
that was just a morbid uh stop i don't
know those that was uh that's
this is a hell of a stock in me i don't
know why this was a stock image but
getty why do you have in what sometimes
you look at stock images and you think
in what context
would someone want to use this something
what was the direction they had when
someone said honestly honestly i i do
think there is a like small market
i'm a small market of stock image
photographers that are like i'm hoping
this is going to become a meme
i'm i'm betting that this is i'm going
to take some meme photos and hope that
this is
this is like they're all like racing to
be the next meme right yeah
to become the next jealous girlfriend
meme guy like that
this is this is definitely giving me
that energy right now for sure
all right this is the the unexpected if
you will let me show you the stock image
first of all what a good stocking
okay that's a tarantino shot right there
my cigar with the boys we kidnapped
somebody
so yeah no one one time uh like you like
you said like the
the mothers bring the door that'll just
bring the mothers along
yeah yeah um and one time there was like
they were both really big fans
wow that's so [ __ ] cool yeah and um
yeah i didn't really think much of it
and like she was like joking being like
oh you she said i look like
like tom cruise i'm like i do not like
tom cruise
i look quite the opposite of tom cruise
is this basically every reddit post who
has like a white guy with a beard and a
shirt
that looks like corner that does oh yeah
it's kind of called the white beard
checks out
then i was like ah okay and then they
were like oh yeah you seeing anyone like
legit asked me this like wow
the mom was yeah the mom asked me that
while i'm signing the daughter's
autograph and i thought oh
yeah no not really not really she's like
oh okay i mean you want to get a drink
later and i'm like
ah and i was like yeah sure sure sure
thinking like oh
it's like this isn't serious yeah yeah
yeah found out later she's
very serious right and she was very
disappointed that we didn't have that
drink right right because i i i thought
it was juicy basically stood her up
i mean she didn't taste it up a milf
not proud to say it the world is going
to end i'm trying to say it you know but
yeah i do connor i'd expect i believe it
was a single mother as well actually
okay oh
that's like a fantasy yeah i mean
i think they think of milf porn right
you don't see the kids so
that's a big plus right i don't [ __ ]
know about the kids don't tell me about
the kid i don't want to get involved
what's wrong maylene you get married and
they have to call you dad
that's so gross i mean some people are
into the daddy thing right
no no it's the fantasy it's the fantasy
listen the problem with the whole like
milf dynamic in real life is there a lot
of hurdles that make it
very uncomfortable and very awkward
right i would feel so sorry for the
[ __ ] daughter imagine being a fan i
felt sorry for the daughter imagine
being a fan of a youtuber
and then they become your dad but let's
just
let's just think about that for a second
that is a [ __ ] like
that is a like a visual novel in the
making
he was my favorite youtuber but now he's
my dad
but actually it was the daughter that
ended up being like oh i'm so sorry my
mom just gets carried away sometimes
right
i'm like yeah your mum's on like the
prowl what's going on
look at the dynamic you guys look like
real huge mode you guys are real close
to be like scouting out the prey with
each other you know what i mean mom's
like yo yo become my
wing woman
it's like it's like love triangles you
know in a porno or a hentai yeah it's
very attractive and
but you realize in real life [ __ ] it's a
nightmare yeah it's messy as far as you
have anything like that never ends well
that was definitely unexpected that's
what that was that was the unexpected
yeah uh
i actually got hit on overwatch one time
oh yeah that was fun also
oh someone recognized who i was and then
added i added them i started playing
with them
and just casually started inquiring you
know about my love life and stuff and
that's normal well they're like
role-playing
or anything like this like what like
which part of this i wish part of your
career was the sin which part of the
career
when did overwatch come out it was like
literally like three or four months into
overwatch being released oh okay okay
that was a while ago then i was like
four or five years yikes
i'm old whenever i watch came out this
happened um
and yeah i i remember just being a bit
awkward because they kept asking like
when someone normally inquires about
your love life
a bit of a comfortable amount you don't
really know them which is
fine i mean you can ask me about that
i'm pretty open about it i don't really
want talking about it but then when you
proceed to like ask me like
the next step you live in like you live
in like
norway i don't know it's kind of far i
don't really know what's in norway
there's no benefits to getting married
someone in norway you know yeah i'm
joking i'm joking
uh yeah and then this is uh yeah this is
it wow
this is almost what it was like at the
urinal for me
so when we when we see each other the
urinal uh or you know
what are you saying urinal urinal
is that what americans say that's why
that's what the british say right no we
say
uranus yeah i thought the british say
urinal no americans say urinal
yeah i guess i've never heard someone
say urinal before
i said you're right i've only yeah i've
only heard british people say you know
what i
it gets i get confused on what words i'm
saying i'm british and american because
people constantly correct me yeah i know
i'm not wrong
yeah but they say why does he say it
like that and then i end up
unconsciously changing it
so i go back to the uk and all my
everyone mocks me for sounding america
yeah i don't even know
what like sometimes i say a word and i
don't even know if that's said in a
british way or an american yeah yeah
yeah but that's it that's the powerful
presentation boom done
thank you that was that was a hell of a
presentation thank you thanks thank you
for your ted talk
sir thanks guys thank you why aren't you
clapping
clap ladder mail i couldn't hear you
what lessons did we learn um
connors fans are [ __ ] weird if you
are
a woman above the age of 35 yeah is that
what you think my demo is yeah i don't
[ __ ] know
yeah i don't know i just like all of
them you aren't correct
older than you like i i okay listen
right
you can see well how are you right now
24 i'm 24 right okay
so like 20 24 24 and a half year olds
are gonna be like
some some people age like wine man they
age better man they
they they get more attractive why are
you laughing man it's true though
it's true like you see pictures of like
uh you see them when they're younger
like celebrities you see them when
they're older you're like
holy [ __ ] he's 50 but he's hotter than
he ever was yeah right i agree
you know honestly to me it's like as
long as the mindset is there that you're
like
you know you're in my world and you're
on the same wavelength of thinking and
you treat life the same way i don't give
a [ __ ] about your age
yeah i mean i feel like some people use
your heart i just don't want you to be
younger than me
because i i feel like some people just
hit a certain age and then they just
stop giving a [ __ ] about how they look
and taking care of themselves right
or alternatively they just think they
can get away with the lifestyle they had
in their 20s
and just bring that to like their the
their 50s
like 30s 40s and 50s because you know i
think being 30 now
as the only 30 year olds i i've heard
that being 30 is just basically being 20
with one debuff
um that's [ __ ] blood yeah
yeah and uh yeah i mean i feel like some
people do age like [ __ ] fine wine and
a lot of asians just don't age at all i
guess
until they've reached like this cap and
then they just start aging and then
they're like oh oh we have to age
oh okay okay honestly um also going back
to the
naming after my baby it wasn't an insult
by the way trying to make sure that's
clear i don't think that's like a bad
thing
just thought it was very intense just i
mean it's a very light a lot i mean i've
never heard any other story like that
it's
like it's so overwhelming that you're
like which emotion do i take away
like i put myself in your shoes and the
biggest like
if if i'm like trying to be like pov you
are connor holding a baby that's named
duffy i'm like
how do i even pump music
how do i even manage what to say right
now i wouldn't even know how to react
it's like a mixture of like overwhelming
flattery
overwhelming like what the [ __ ] yeah are
you sure about this
are you sure about that yeah yeah it's
like is this a mistake are you going to
regret this because
i'm not all that right yeah um what else
we take away from the powerful
presentation boys
what did you learn you get hit on a lot
no no no it's actually you know we get
hit on
so my audience has gone from as we know
93 percent
it's uh recently it went to like like 60
mail um is my jojo i think also
there was a good amount of time where i
think because of my thumbnails because
the tops i was covering youtube just
didn't recommend me to guys
yeah and now it suddenly started being
like oh wait guys can watch this guy too
yeah i started getting a massive influx
of guy viewers that i never had before
right right um and i stopped doing as
much yowie stuff and slowed down on that
but
i mean it's still like nearly it's like
it depends on the month it's like
depending on the videos i make yeah it's
about 50 50 now which is nice and it's
slowed down a lot
uh but there's ups and down sides right
like it was mainly like i i know that i
spoke about like mainly like it was like
girls coming up to me but
dude guys hit on me just as much uh
really yeah yeah i've had that which is
flattering because there was like one
dude who's in
my instagram message request matt was
[ __ ] ripped as [ __ ] and i was like
wow
i'm i'm very flattered this man had like
the body of a greek statue and this man
thought i was worthy of being hit on i
was very i was very fast
oh man jealous yeah right i was like
damn
but uh yeah i mean it's it's it's it's
whatever it's
[ __ ] youtube yeah i mean what what i
can take about this is that if there is
going to be an avenue not necessarily to
be hit on but
for someone to get in contact with
contact with you because half
i would say half of these were just you
know the fan interactions or people
trying to get in contact with you if
there's an avenue
people are going to find a way and i've
definitely felt that as a youtuber as
well
yeah i mean you can hit on me it's very
flattering i don't care you don't have
to stop doing it just don't be creepy
just do it in a sophisticated way yeah
man you do it slick i'll be like thank
you for the ego boost i'm going to go
away feeling great though yeah
yeah who doesn't dude when you get hit
on you're like damn i'm a tan
and then you go back to your hotel room
in a whole bag of flaming hot cheetos
and realize you're truly a five
and also the on the opposite end any
uh taking this advice for any like young
budding youtubers out there
like tread carefully with fans hitting
on you don't [ __ ] your fans man
it never works out listen you know it
might work out one tenth of the time but
there's the problem is is that but are
you willing to take the risk yeah
i mean you have to be really careful and
i think the biggest problem
is that whenever whenever you're like a
youtuber starting out especially when
you're a small youtuber i feel like
this is more a message to small
youtubers
um who don't have the experience or
don't think they're gonna get big
because you don't [ __ ] know if you're
gonna get big
right but you should treat you should
treat the fans or you should treat your
audience
no matter how big you are exactly the
same and it's it's stay grounded yeah
i mean i'm sure there's cringy messages
out there of me hitting on someone at 19
that would just embarrass me but it's
again i'm 19 you know just [ __ ] yeah
but like you're you're like
it wasn't like hit on fans of me like
shimmy nudes you know what i mean it's
just like
just me being an average 19 year old
yeah exactly like when you're younger
like you don't you don't really have
like the senses to know what exactly is
cringe you're not
also when you're younger you're just
hoarding as [ __ ] yeah exactly and
and you think you can get away with you
know being horny
and you grow up and you realize man i
did a lot of stupid [ __ ] yeah
yeah young dumb and full of calm that's
as they say
lovely joey words to live by yeah but i
mean it's
it's like because there's some people
you know there's a lot of youtubers
out there very very openly happy to
admit that they date fans they're like
well
you know the normal famous celebrities
get to [ __ ] their fans and no one bets
an eye
and it's like well i mean yeah that
double standard is like
this is the way i interpret it and why
that's the case that normal celebrities
they don't bank on the fact of
relatability they don't bank on the fact
of being
they're like people above the club well
their whole like every like pop star
is supposed to be like a character like
an absurd kind of
not real person yeah right they never
pretend to be your friend
they never like pretend to give a [ __ ]
about you yeah and if you have sex with
them they'll probably don't give a [ __ ]
about it right maybe
maybe right it's just a joke but i mean
if you do it with an influencer right or
crossword or a youtuber right i i hate
that
i guess it's almost kind of a betrayal
of what you built up which is like
a lot of the people who watch us right i
guess i don't know if you guys know like
you guys feel this way like there's a
you form like a bit of a bond right
where you like you respect the creator
and
yeah you look up to them and you enjoy
their stuff and you feel a lot closer to
a youtuber than you would say
yeah because and so it's that that's
being taken advantage right it's because
most youtubers are more
i guess grounded right you feel more
real so when you do watch them you're
just like oh
this is an actual person i'm watching
yeah like like i would say
to be like the right way to go about it
is if you're if you're going to get
involved with your fans
that you just one of the biggest things
is you don't do it straight away
like you need to treat as a friend start
as a friend treat them like a human
being
get the get to know each other first
like any normal [ __ ] relationship
you need to like immediately like break
down or disassemble any like power
dynamic in play
i was like and and like you put yourself
on equal footing yeah and with stuff
like one night stands or something
that's
that gets so messy and there's no way to
like differentiate
is there a power dynamic there is is is
the person is the person gonna do this
and then you know regret it afterwards
and just
it it's too messy to be able to justify
i feel um and if there is a right way to
go about it and
there's nothing about it but like most
of the time it's like you know
it's like do you want to defuse a bomb
like you if you know how to
yeah you want to do that yeah go ahead
there's a right way to do it but it's
not worth it right yeah but like is it
worth is it like
is it worth the risk literally blowing
yourself up in terms of career like is
it worth it or you could just
i don't know be do what everyone else
[ __ ] does i don't know well
date normally and i feel like a lot of
smaller youtubers don't
like they they don't really think about
this because they think i've got nothing
to lose so i'm just going to do this
right now while
while i can because you grew up in a
culture where yeah you do see you know
celebrities and like groupies cats like
sleeping with
you know music artists and everything
like that you think man
that sounds like an awesome lifestyle i
kind of like that stuff so when they get
like a
smidgen of that they think i gotta take
advantage of this
while i still can rock and roll
lifestyle works if you're in that field
the rocker roll lifestyle is not the
youtuber lifestyle it's two completely
different things i find
yeah it's it's tough it's so tough and
it's like is it just like it's not even
worth
like getting into yeah right because i
feel like to get involved in this is
it's
you are literally navigating a minefield
oh yeah 100
it's like if you really want to do it
you can do it yeah but
the reason why i think most youtubers
will say don't [ __ ] your fans is because
it's just like it's so much it's so much
risk you're taking on for no reason
like it and and to me it's like do you
really want someone who wants to be with
you
for your videos is that like why is that
attractive like
they're looking at you only for the
right because to me it's a competitive
mindset
to me that's like a massive turn off if
they're only with me
because of my content then that's like
the same thing if you're only my friends
for my content then you i'm saying you
can't be my friend because that's that's
not how i would see a friend yeah
the same way i that's how i wouldn't see
like a possible partner
like that's like saying like also if i
change my content then you're suddenly
not my friend
yeah yeah i there is no bigger turn on
right than meeting someone who just
likes you for you yeah like
what why why i'm sitting there i'm
thinking like how the [ __ ] am i supposed
to be into this
and then like get my dick hard when i'm
all i'm thinking about you're thinking
is like what's the next upload going to
be
like [ __ ] that no i i want someone who
like speaks to me knows nothing about
youtube and it's like holy [ __ ]
like this guy's [ __ ] cool i like him
yeah he's so nice you want people to see
you as connor not c dog
yeah yeah which obviously i made a bit
difficult for myself obviously but
i can still go about it yeah of course
you know you don't want to be with a
girl
be in bed and be like yo if you enjoyed
that session hit the subscribe button
click the like button
if we get to 5 000 likes i'll do round
two
[Laughter]
i want a youtube video of someone trying
to do that
oh my god yeah i feel like oh my god
yeah there's
so many [ __ ] douche tubers out there
who do [ __ ]
i'm sure there's youtubers out there who
just admit every single [ __ ] day like
yeah i [ __ ] my fans so well and like
i mean screw them but if you want to
have like you know something if you want
to be respected by the community
yeah if you want to be seen as like a
role model don't know what that is
yeah i mean like douche tubers i feel
just exist on a different plane of
existence where
i don't know how they function or you
know
i i just i just want youtubers to have a
better rap right like
not all of us are [ __ ] psychopath
uh chasing you know
like yeah a lot of a lot of us are horny
[ __ ] and that's that's just
the that's just human nature that is the
only
we are three horny guys but at least
we're horny on main and uh
we we keep to being horny on maine and
uh that's pretty much it yeah
pretty much man a part of me is part of
me as glad is that you i have like
youtube to keep me in chat almost
not that i would start doing awful [ __ ]
if i wasn't a youtuber but
the fact that there is this kind of like
obvious moral lines that
right that it's not like oh no man
should i do no no it's not they're like
these unspoken guidelines and rules to
like make sure you're not
right yeah it really makes me cautious
about how i come up to people and what i
say to people makes me way more
conscious about how i speak
in a way that i think is you know i the
way i speak
on live streams the way i speak you know
on the video is how i'll speak to
most people in my life and how yeah you
know and i like that
it's kind of taught me in a way to just
it sounds awful right but just give a
[ __ ] about everything
and pay attention even if it is draining
at times it sounds awful i'm like yeah
you should taught me to be
not an [ __ ] like but like you know
how some things you take for granted
yeah that you when you're you know when
you're an individual who isn't like uh
open person yeah i mean for me it's it's
not it didn't teach me to
you know give a [ __ ] about everything
but it did teach me to really
question my own values yeah and
and really justify if is is this value i
hold right
right as opposed to like i just think
about
i just think it this way because i was i
grew up in that kind of environment
and it really made me self-reflect and i
feel like that that is like
a healthy part of youtube that has has i
think i've become
a better person because of youtube yeah
like it's it's about that mentality of
like
okay if i wasn't doing youtube then do
is the things that i do and the way that
i talk to people and what kind of stuff
would that be still considered
respectful to other people
regardless of if i were if i had this
job or not like would i still be a good
person if i didn't have youtube
and if the answer is yes then i think
you're following it right if you're
worrying if the answer is no
yeah well i mean you know look at all
the douche tubers right apparently you
can get away with that [ __ ]
if you have a youtube channel i don't
know do they get away with that [ __ ]
though
like i mean i mean there's a reason why
they have an audience are they they are
on borrowed time are they like a twit
longer waiting to happen
because they're definitely like a limit
like they're not going to be like
at the point that they are for very long
because i feel like a big
i mean this is getting to a really deep
topic now but a big problem with
a lot of these like apology videos and
you know
a lot of this kind of culture that that
has been built up i understand where it
comes from where we we do need to keep
in
uh we do need to keep each other in
check and make sure that people aren't
abusing their power
but a part of it just makes me feel like
man people are just treating this like
one big reality tv show
it's not keeping each other checked
we've just made it a modern coliseum
yeah we just we just gamified it
basically we've just you know
could we can't kill each other that's
the best thing we can do is [ __ ] get
each other's throats
yeah which is which is why right now now
when i see an apology video or twit
longer
you know like a lot a lot of like as we
said we were taught to you know
have to give a [ __ ] about this thing but
sometimes i see this and i'm like
i don't have the energy to keep the [ __ ]
to care about this this doesn't involve
me
you know sometimes it it it [ __ ]
sucks when i
when i hear about you know some some
person in the community or in some
community
that i'm not even involved with doing
like having like a five
five fifty page more like 50 page
dissertation breaking down every shitty
thing they've done
and i'm like i'm sorry that this
happened but at the same time
like i don't have the energy to invest
myself into this
can someone literally give me a cliff
notes of what's going on and like
i don't want to be the guy to be like
can you tell me what to think
but there there reaches a point where
there is too much happening right now
that's you can you can it's it's it's
it's like
sensory overload yeah yeah it's just
like
at the end of the day all i'm seeing is
someone's getting [ __ ] paid leave
that's all i'm seeing yeah it's like i
have limited time i've limited energy
and i want to be able to use it on [ __ ]
i actually
care about yeah yeah like i i would like
to care about
every big scandal every big thing that
gets you know brought up on twitter
and you know that's that logically
and if i think about it that's what i
want to value but
logistically you can't you can't you
can't care about this much [ __ ]
and i feel like a big problem right now
is that
this this entire environment just feels
like
big brother or this feels like a real
reality tv show where
people care but do they really care like
they get to a point where
this is really what i think does this
really involve me does this
you know am i doing something right to
society by getting involved with this
or am i just feeding the fumes and the
fire and just making the environment
more toxic
nothing's stopping if you don't care
that everyone hates you
yeah and you're fine with that there's
literally nothing stopping you from
succeeding i mean there's people who
make a career off of being hated right
so funny
yeah yeah i mean it's one of the biggest
examples of course logan paul
and one of i i can't remember who said
this quote but
it was you know i think it was like
muhammad ali or
a boxer where they say well they said
something like
if uh people will pay to like
what was it people will pay to watch you
to shut you up
yeah people will pay to watch you get
punched yeah watch get punched or watch
you or watch
the [ __ ] something along man logan paul
has capitalized that
to the max i mean i i'll [ __ ] admit
you know
you know i i got involved with whenever
logan paul gets and uh gets into a
boxing match
of course i did i want to see logan paul
get punched bunch yeah she's funny you
know i mean
i don't really have anything personally
against the guy obviously but no it's
just
fun seeing two usually smack each other
in the face this [ __ ] is funny as [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i'd do that if the right target came up
i'm like yo how much money did he make
put me in the ring y'all give me some
beef please
give me some beef to fight over
pay-per-view yeah like
yeah that's scary how it's evolved to
that point isn't it it's like
it makes you wonder what the next step
is like we're going we're going back to
where we started where
you know when reality is this
entertaining who the [ __ ] needs tv
that's what i've been saying the whole
time gone reality has always been more
entertaining documentaries
yeah man you can't make this [ __ ] up man
you you can make up all these
harry potters and lord the rings that's
that's epic and all i love those films
but
you can't make up the weird [ __ ] that
happens in real life yeah and that's
been trash taste but you know what
hasn't been trash taste uh
without us reading the patrons that
didn't make any sense
at all
look at all these patrons they love them
this guy has gigabrain gigamonkeybrain
yeah
if you'd like to join the patron then as
always go to patreon.com
trash taste uh also follow us on twitter
you'll get it
early from the episode so you can watch
them early and if we do any uncensored
versions you'll get them yeah yeah be
sure to check it out
but send memes on twitter subreddit and
listen to us on spotify
don't send us a face don't send nudes
please
don't do that we don't do that
yes but uh anyway that's been this
episode of trash taste
uh do you wanna you wanna take this over
connor you're the host you're the host
yeah it's been a great episode of trash
taste nate the best episode
let me know if you want more powerpoint
presentations in the future i'll be
happy to oblige with more
but yeah let me know down below what you
thought of my presentation name my ted
talk sorry
it's not just a presentation rate his
ted talk yeah very much had to go out of
town
all right see you guys bye
[Music]
you